TO GET STARTED MY APOLOGIES FOR
RUNNING JUST A LITTLE BIT LATE
TODAY AS YOU CAN APPRECIATE
THEIR NUMBER OF MULTI TASKING
THAT'S GOING ON BETWEEN.
VARIOUS COMMITTEES AND MAKING
PRESENTATIONS AND THEN SHARING
OR PARTICIPATING AND OTHERS --
BUT WE LIKE TO AT LEAST --
WRECK WELCOME A SENATOR WINNER --
TO MAKE HIS PRESENTATION. TO US
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THIS
MOMENT ON SB.
SEVEN HUNDRED MY APOLOGIES FOR
THE DELAY.
VELVET NEMESIS HERE.
OKAY IT AND LET ME JUST IF I
COULD -- FOR
PURPOSES OF HOUSEKEEPING EVEN
THOUGH SHE IS NOT HERE --
PRESENTLY I MISS FRIEDMAN WILL
BE SITTING IN TODAY.
A TO FILL THE VACANCY ON OUR
COMMITTEE ON OUR COMMITTEE.
AND THAT WE HAVE --
UNDER HOUSEKEEPING WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF CONSIDER BILLS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TEND.
TO ITEM SIX S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX HERTZBERG.
ITEM SEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT HUESO.
ITEM NINE S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HUESO WITH AMENDMENTS.
ITEM TEN S. B. FOURTEEN TEN
MORALE.
AND SO WITH THAT.
DURING WINTER YOU'RE ON THE
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT SETBACK
THANK YOU YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
BILL.
I AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AYE AMENDMENTS CONTAINED IN THE
ANALYSIS OF THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OUGHT COLLEAGUES US SENATE BILL
SEVEN HUNDRED OF WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION OPT FOR THE SMALL
SCALE BEHIND THE METER STORAGE.
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGY --
BY EXTENDING A CRITICAL
INCENTIVE --
PROGRAM FOR THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
ODD DISTRIBUTED STORAGE
RESOURCES ARE A CRITICAL --
TO ADDRESSING THE MID DAY
SURPLUS OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
CALLED COURSE THE TUCKER --
WHERE WE ARE PRODUCING A LOT OF
SOLO DURING THE DAY --
AND THEN USING A LOT OF IT AT
NIGHT WHEN THE SUN IS NO LONGER.
A SHINING AND SO WE WANT PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE.
URGES NOT FLOWING BACK INTO THE
GRID AND SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
TAPPING INTO AYE PICKER PLANT
ENERGY ON THE RETURN HOME AT
NIGHT.
AIDID'S --
BEHIND THE METER STORAGE SYSTEMS
CAN PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RESILIENCY.
TODD DURING TIMES OF WILDFIRE
OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS I WOULD
TRADITIONAL DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS
MAY BE SEVERED OR POWERED DOWN.
ARE UNFORTUNATELY THE ITSELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM OR
ASK SHIP.
WHICH HAS BEEN A CRUCIAL DRIVER
OF GROWTH IN THE STORAGE MARKET.
IS SET TO EXPIRE --
ON JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH REVENUE
COLLECTION ENDING A YEAR EARLIER --
THAN THAT I SUCH A SCENARIO IS
PROJECTED OUGHT TO LEAD TO ONLY
SEVEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
STORAGE CAPACITY INSTALLED ON
THE PROGRAM WHICH IS FAR LESS.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO BRING THE
MARKET THE SCALE.
AYE SO ARE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS WORK
IT'S WORKED OUT WITH ROOFTOP
SOLAR -- IT
IS WORKING ON WILL WORK I WITH A
STORAGE SYSTEMS.
AND THE SB SEVEN HUNDRED BY
EXTENDING THE ESTA PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE A CRITICAL NOTS
CERTAINTY ONTO THE ENERGY
STORAGE INDUSTRY.
ARE A MINISTRY I THAT WE NEED --
UNDER A FIVE YEAR EXTENSION
ABOUT CHIP WITH BOTH IN THE BILL
OF THE PROGRAM CAN GENERATE AS
MANY AS TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
MEGAWATTS OF STORAGE.
WHILE DRIVING PRICE REDUCTIONS
IN BOTH TECHNOLOGY AND HARD WORK
COSTS AS WELL AS SOFT COSTS SUCH
AS INSTALLATION PERMITTING
CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT.
I MEAN WELL AS CHIP WILL
CONTINUE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS LOWER ENERGY
DEMAND.
IMPROVE GREAT RELIABILITY AND
FOSTER THE GROWTH OF DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES.
AND PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S VERY --
POSITIVE FOR OUR RECENT DECISION
TO REQUIRE A SOLAR ON NEARLY ALL
NEW ROOF TOPS S. B. SEVEN
HUNDRED WILL ALLOW CUSTOMERS BUY
TO USE --
SELF GENERATED SOLAR POWER AYE
DURING PEAK HOURS ARE RATHER
THAN RELYING ON UTILITY
ELECTRICITY WHICH WILL SAVE
MONEY -- AND
AVOID --
OTHER --
CHALLENGES --
SO WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE OUT
BERNADETTE DEL CHARO OF THE
CALIFORNIA SO A SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION.
AND THEN JACOB SAN OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
I THINK YOU UP MY NAME IS PART
OF THAT DON'T YOU ARE ONLY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION.
OF WHERE THE LARGEST CLEAN
ENERGY A BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
OVER FIVE HUNDRED OF MEMBER
COMPANIES THAT ARE INSTALLING
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTING.
AT SOLAR AND ENERGY STORAGE
SYSTEMS AND COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANNA THANK THE CHAIR A AND A
STAFFER WORKING.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR SUPPORT.
AND OF COURSE WE WANT THINK ARE
AUTHORED --
FOR HELPING CHAMPION THIS ISSUE
SB SEVEN HUNDRED IS URGENTLY
NEEDED.
OF FOR CONTINUED GROWTH OF OUR
INDUSTRY IN OF DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES.
IT ALSO PROVIDES THREE CRITICAL
BENEFITS TO ALL RATEPAYERS AND
WANT TO BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL MULTI YEAR AND SENT
TO PROGRAMS LIKE WITH THIS BILL
WOULD EXTEND.
WORK IN TERMS OF DRIVING DOWN
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS.
WE KNOW FROM OUR EXPERIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INITIATIVE.
THAT THE PRICE OF SOLAR DECLINE
60% OVER THE COURSE OF THAT
TENURE PROGRAM.
WHILE DRIVING UP DEMAND AND
IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF THESE
PROGRAMS CONTINUED LONG AFTER
THE REBATES SUNSET.
PACIFIC LEYVA PAST TWO YEARS
CALIFORNIA SOLAR MARKET HAS
TRIPLED.
IT'S THE END OF THE REBATES.
AND PRICES HAVE CONTINUED
DECLINE WE WOULD EXPECT A
SIMILAR EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH ENERGY STORAGE SHOULD SB
SEVEN HUNDRED ASS.
SECONDLY DISTRIBUTE ENERGY
RESOURCES SAVE ALL RATEPAYERS
MONEY.
JUST THIS PAST MARCH CAL I SO
ANNOUNCED THAT DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES STABS SAVED
RATEPAYERS TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS AND REDUCED NEED FOR UP
TRANSMISSION UPGRADES.
IS A REAL VALUE FOR ALL
RATEPAYERS AND THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF ADDITIONAL VALUES AND
SAVINGS THAT ENERGY STORAGE
DEPLOYED AS SUCH AS ENVISIONED
BY SB SEVEN HUNDRED WILL
CONTINUE TO BRING ALL RATEPAYERS.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST ENERGY
STORAGE MAKES OUR GREAT MORE
RESILIENT ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF
EXTREME CLIMATE EVENTS SUCH AS
THE WILDFIRES.
AS YOU THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE IF WE ARE SUCCESSFULLY
ABLE TO DEPLOY MORE ENERGY
STORAGE AND PAIRED WITH SOLAR
SYSTEMS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE CAN AT TIMES OF HIGH WIND
EVENTS FOR EXAMPLE DEPOWER --
VULNERABLE TRANS I'D JUST IN
LIGHTS ON FOR ARE CRITICAL --
TO AT FACILITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ACTUALLY HELP
PREVENT SOME OF THESE FIRES FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
US WITHOUT I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE --
AGAIN OUR THANKS AYE TO THAT THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORT --
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR MAINTAINING
THE JOBS THAT WE PROVIDE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE GIVING
CONSUMER MORE CHOICE AND HELPING
CALIFORNIA --
BUILDUP CLEANER GREENER GRAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
BEFORE WE TAKE OUR NEXT WITNESS
WE'RE GOING.
TO A TURN THERE ARE --
COMMITTEE SECRETARY FOR A ROLL
CALL WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
LET'S.
TAKE THE ROLE.
HOLDEN.
PRESENT [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
QUIRK YOUR REYES SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS DAN JACOBSON
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO WHAT THE SENATOR.
AND KELSEY YEAH CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE HAS BEEN SAYING
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
IS NOT JUST THIS BILL BUT THE
CONCEPT OF MOVING US TOWARD A
100% HAS BEEN IMPORTANT.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE CRITICAL PIECES THAT GET US
THERE I KNOW WILL HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AGAIN LATER BUT I
THINK YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
THE CONVERSATION.
AWAY FROM A SINGLE BILL AND LOOK
AT IT AS A WHOLE AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO DO
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR BEING ABLE TO TO SORT OF PUT
A PAUSE ON THING TAKE A BIGGER
LOOK AT THINGS AND I THINK
THAT'S BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT TO
DO.
I WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT S. B.
SEVEN HUNDRED IN PARTICULAR IS
CRITICAL FOR BEING ABLE TO GET
US TO THAT 1100% GOAL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING.
FOR IT IT DOES IS THE SENATOR
HAS ALREADY SAID.
ALLOWS US TO USE THE EXCESS
SOLAR CAPACITY THAT WE HAVE
DURING THE DAY TO BE ABLE TO
THEN USE THAT IN THE EVENING
INSTEAD OF HAVING OUR HOME SURE
OUR BUSINESSES.
LOCK IN TWO PETER PLANTS AND
THAT'S GONNA BE ONE OF THE
CRITICAL THINGS THAT WE NEED NOT
ONLY FOR CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT.
BUT I THINK JUST AS IMPORTANT TO
REDUCE.
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION HAS
AGAIN COME OUT WITH THEIR LIST
CALIFORNIA TOPS THAT LIST SIX
OUT OF THE TOP TEN CITIES IN
THERE ARE FROM CALIFORNIA WE'VE
GOT TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN.
TO HELP REDUCE THAT AIR
POLLUTION BILLS LIKE THIS ARE A
CRITICAL PIECE.
THE SECOND THING I'LL SAY IS
THAT WE NEED THIS TO CONTINUE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP WE'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED HOW SUCCESSFUL
THE SOLAR ROOFS PROGRAM IS BEEN
A MILLION SOLDIERS PROGRAM.
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
AT HELPING TO GET SOLAR PANELS
OUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT
DRIVE DOWN THE PRICE AND THE
THIRD REASON THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING THIS IS THERE'S A 25%
OF THIS.
IS MADE SURE THAT IT'S GOING TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THIS TIME
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CLEAN ENERGY REVOLUTION.
IS 21100% OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THAT NO ONE IS LEFT OUT WE WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SCOTT
MURDER SAW I'M WORKING AS A
CONSULTANT TO THE CALIFORNIAN.
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION --
PRIOR TO WORKING FOR KELSO.
AYE WHAT WHAT'S BEEN ELEVEN
YEARS THAT THE CPU SEE OVER
SEVEN OF WHICH IS WORKING TO
SHAPE THE EXTRA PROGRAM IN
VARIOUS WAYS AS AN ADVISER TO
TWO DIFFERENT PRESIDENTS THERE.
SO I'M HERE TO HELP ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE BACKGROUND OF THE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOT TAKE OF THOSE WHO
ARE HERE. TO TO LEND THEIR
SUPPORT --
WITH THAT ME TO NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
DEFINITENESS CHAIR JUSTIN FANS
ON BEHALF OF TECHNO HUMAN
SUPPORT THINK.
AFTERNOON JASON VARGAS WITH THAT
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT.
SILVIO HURRYING TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES SENSATION SOME POWER
CORPORATIONS.
JIM WINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HELLO KNOWING I OUT THOUGH WITH
SOME RUN IN SUPPORT.
GOVERNOR WAS TERMINAL BURDEN TO
RECALL AND HAVE FOR THE LAST FOR
SOLAR CHOICE IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER AND ON
BEHALF OF FOSSIL FREE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
DO ANY HUNDRED WE HAVE ADVANCED
MICRO GOOD SOLUTIONS THE CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY AND THE
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION OWN SUPPORT.
WALKER RIGHT WITH AND YOU
STORAGE IN SUPPORT.
RICH POOR ABOUT WITH JK BE
ENERGY GUERRA LEAVING UP
PROVIDER OF SOLAR POWER FOR
FARMS THROUGHOUT THE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WE THINK THIS IMPORTANT
STEP AND ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT.
MADELINE SANTA WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
AND JD WIN WITH THE BARE SOLAR
AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU.
I WOULD GET ON A ON BEHALF OF
PERREGAUX SOLAR IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
TYLER DALTON ON BEHALF OF BEAR
SOLAR AND FULL SUPPORT.
AL RICH PRESIDENT OF ACR SOLAR
CARMICHAEL SOLAR MANUFACTURE IN
SUPPORT.
THE MAMMOTH FROM BEAR SOARING
SUPPORT FOR S. B..
SEVEN HUNDRED HI ALEX MORRIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STORAGE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
MICROSOFT NOW BEHALF OF SOME
WORKS WE FULLY SUPPORT S. B.
SANDRA.
SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
TROUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SAYS HAITIAN
WE DO NOT HAVE A SUPERPOSITION
BUT WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US AND WE CAN NO LONGER HAPPEN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
ANTHONY SAMPSON ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY ALSO HERE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NO I MEAN THEY ARE NOT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF VOTE SOLAR AS SOMEONE
IS A MEMBER OF BUT SOLAR AND
THEY'RE IN SUPPORT.
EXPECTS WITH MYERS SOLAR AND
IT'S ON SOLAR IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
IN.
I NEED TO MAKE A LITTLE ROOM
THERE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
ISRAEL SALAS WITH OF SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY --
FIRST WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR THE
WORK ON THE BILL.
OB UNFORTUNATELY EVEN AS THE
EYES PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED WE
STILL MUST REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
WE SUPPORT THE GOALS OF REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE
SUPPORT THE ROLE THAT ENERGY
STORAGE CAN PLAY --
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE AND WHERE
IT'S COST EFFECTIVE
UNFORTUNATELY WE DISAGREE WITH
SOME OF THE --
SOME OF THE CHARACTERIZATIONS
ABOUT HOW THE STORAGE DEVICES
ARE BEING USED TODAY.
OUT WE BELIEVE THAT ACCORDING.
TWO AND I TRUMP STUDY THAT WAS
RELEASED OUT WHICH MEASURES AND
EVALUATES THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE BATTERIES AS
A RESULT OF THE AFTER PROGRAM
WHAT THEY HAVE SHOWN IS THAT IT
INCREASING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS NOT DECREASING.
WE AGREE THAT CHARGING THE
BATTERY PACKS DURING THE MID DAY
WHEN SOLDIERS PLENTIFUL IS A
GOOD IDEA.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS CHARGING
DURING THE SYSTEM PEAK IS A GOOD
IDEA BUT UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THE OPPOSITE --
DISCHARGING OR CHARGING DURING
DURING THE PEAK AND DISCHARGING --
IT DURING DAYS WHEN SO WHERE IS
PLENTIFUL SO UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL --
WE CAN SEE SOME MEANINGFUL
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE.
RAPE PARA BENEFIT SEALED IT'S
ALL OF OUR RATEPAYERS OUT WE
MUST REMAIN OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTIVE ENOUGH
FLEMING'S ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY --
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL
WHAT IT TO WHAT IS IN PRINT
TODAY AYE WE DO NEED TO GO BACK
AND REEVALUATE OF THE AMENDMENTS
GIVEN THE AUTHORS ACCEPTANCE OF
THE NEW LANGUAGE --
BUT WE WOULD I JUST WANT TO ADD
THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REALLY
CONSIDER AND KEEP A WATCHFUL EYE
ON ENSURING GREAT CARE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE SG IP WILL BE SPENT
PRUDENT LEAD TO MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFIT FOR ALL UTILITY
CUSTOMERS AND NOT JUST.
OF THE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS SO
WE WILL BE TAKING ANOTHER LOOK
AT THE BILL --
AND IF IT CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD --
IF WE HAVE TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
CHAIRMAN NURSE REBECCA LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE TO HAVE A REGISTER
OPPOSED POSITION BASED ON THE
BILL IMPRINTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT'S A SEPARATE
TODAY -- WE
ARE ALSO REALLY REASSESSING OUR
POSITIONING --
BUT ONE THING TO A WE WOULD LIKE
THIS BODY TO ON BE MINDFUL OF IS
AS WE CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM THAT
WE MAKE SURE THE FUNDING LEVEL
FOR THE SYSTEMS A PROPERLY
REFLECT THE LEVEL OF MARK.
KIT TRANSFORMATION WE SEE THAT
AND SEE AND THE SECTOR FOR
EXAMPLE THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
INITIATIVE INITIATIVE PROGRAM
DOES INCENTIVES WERE SET DOWN AS
THE MARKET.
A SOLAR MATURED SO WE WOULD
EXPECT PASSED THE STORAGE MARKET
MATURES THAT THESE INCENTIVES
ARE ADJUSTED AND REEVALUATE IT
APPROPRIATELY --
TO MAKE SURE THAT RATE PER FUNDS
ARE SIMPLE SPENDS MOST PARTLY AS
A ASK RESPONSIBILITY AS
RESPONSIBLE AS POSSIBLE --
WITH THAT --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU.
SO WILL ACCEPT THOSE WHO ARE
HERE TO US --
LYNN THEIR OPPOSITION WITH NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SCOTT WHICH WOULD STAY
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS.
I AND THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES ACTUALLY
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AND WE
OF OUR IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE --
TO WHO HAS A POSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYSON TO MEMBERS OF
DOCTOR QUIRK [inaudible]
BOB.
SO I KNOW ALONE BUT NOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND AT FIRST I SAY I
DID.
I WAS THE DECIDING VOTE TO
REJECT AN EARLIER I'M GOING TO
BE VOTING FOR THE BILL THIS TIME.
ALL AN EARLIER VERSION WHICH
EXPANDED THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS SIMPLY CONTINUING THE
PROGRAM [inaudible]
AND WE AS A STATE BAYLOR
COMMITMENT AND THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY WORKING
VERY HARD RIGHT NOW.
AND WE DO NOT WANT TO BREAK
FAITH WITH THOSE PEOPLE.
SO EXTENDING THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
THESE PROGRAMS ALWAYS TAKE
LONGER THAN YOU THINK.
TIM.
MAKES A LOT OF SAN AND WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
I CAN FULLY SUPPORT THIS --
EDITION BROUGHT UP A TRUE FACT.
WHICH IS THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE CRAZY WAY WE SET
RATES.
NAMELY THAT A COMPANY IS CHARGED
ON ITS MAXIMUM USE EVEN IF IT'S
A TIME WHEN THERE'S PLENTY OF
ENERGY.
COMPANIES ARE DOING THE WRONG
THING.
ARE THE P. UC IS LOOKING AT THIS
I HAVE NO DOUBT THEY WILL
CORRECT IT.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PUT A NUDGE IN
YOUR BILL FOR THEM TO DO THAT.
AB THAT'LL BRING THE OPPOSITION
OFF.
BUT YEAH IT'S IT'S NOT BEING
DONE RIGHT NOW THE P. YOU SEE IS
VERY AWARE OF THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN AND SHOULD BE
FIXED.
IN THE MEANTIME.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE KEEP FAITH WITH THE PROGRAM
THAT WE DO OUR PART AND IT'S
TRUE WE DID OUR PART IN SOLAR
HERE IN THE U. S..
PEOPLE WERE DOING THEIR PART
AROUND THE WORLD IN GERMANY AND
CHINA.
WE ARE NOT THE ONLY ONES DOING
THIS WE ARE NOT THE ONLY ONES
WHO WILL BE PUSHING THIS MARKET
WE WILL HAVE COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE WORLD.
WE HOWEVER NEED TO DO OUR SHARE
SO I WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO
MOVE THIS BILL AND URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE I BLOW WITH
THE AMENDMENTS YES WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE WONDERFUL.
YEAH I'D AND FOR THE RECORD I I
MISSED THE BEGINNING.
BUT WE REFERRING TO THE
AMENDMENTS AND SECTION ONE
PARAGRAPHS BNC HERE WHAT FOR THE
RECORD WHERE THE AMENDMENTS.
THESE ARE THE A MENACE THAT ARE
ATTACHED --
PAGE.
SEVEN THE BILL WAS ANALYZE
BECAUSE PROPOSED TO TO BE
AMENDMENTS. TO IT WITH UNITS
OKAY A AND THEN BUT I GUESS MY
OTHER COMMENT IS IS A ALONG THE
LINES OF OF MICHAEL THE DOCTOR
QUIRK AROUND.
I DO THINK WE NEED SOME KIND OF
WAY TO DO SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND
TIME OF USE AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
USING THE BATTERY --
BUT I KNOW ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO SOME OF THE THE THE
NEW THINGS ARE DOING WITH TAG
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT.
THEM.
HOW WE HOW WE USE OUR OUR
RESOURCES THE MOST EFFECTIVELY --
AND AGAIN WITH EXPANSION THIS
PROGRAM AND IN JUST AT THE
CLARIFICATION I I BELIEVE THIS
WORKS VERY WELL WITH THAT A. B..
SIX AND THREE THAT WE DID LAST
YEAR AMOUNTS OR FOR LOW INCOME
AND AT 25% AND BE ABLE TO BE
USED.
FOR AB DOESN'T IT MULTI FAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT IS USING
SOME THE SORT THEN CAN ALSO.
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BATTERY.
RIGHT.
IT IN AGAIN ALONG WITH LINES
WITH A DOCTOR QUICKLY SAYING IT
WOULD BE VERY NICE TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF GUARDRAILS AROUND TIMES
ABUSE AND BEING OF THE USE.
THE POWER IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MANNER TO BE ABLE TO REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'VE TWO QUESTIONS
AND SORT OF A COMET.
I WAS WONDERING IF SOMEBODY
COULD ADDRESS THE ISSUE RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION --
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN JUST
COMMENTED ON WITH RESPECT TO
PEOPLE.
THIS CHARGING OUT OF THEIR
STORAGE.
NOT AT NIGHTTIME WHEN IN A
PRODUCTION OF SELLERS GONE ZERO
BUT AT OTHER TIMES IN THE DAY
WHETHER.
THAT'S BEEN STUDIED IS THAT.
ACCURATE IS THAT NOT ACCURATE
WHAT SORT OF GOING.
THE OTHER THERE TWO ELEMENTS OF
THAT THAT ARE DRIVING THAT
CHARGING AND DISCHARGING
BEHAVIORS ONE IS.
THAT WE HAVE THESE WATER OFTEN
REFERRED HIS LEGACY TIME OF USE
PERIODS.
BECAUSE BEFORE WE HAD THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR ON THE GRID
THE PEAK.
I AM INTERVIEWS OCCURRED
GENERALLY FROM TWELVE PM TO SIX
PM.
AND FOR VARIOUS REASONS IT TOOK
YEARS FOR THE P..
AND THE VARIOUS RATE CASES TO
MOVE FROM THOSE LEGACY PERIODS
TO THE NEW TIME OF USE PERIODS
THE PEAKS.
THAT REFLECT A ALL THAT ABUNDANT
SOLAR ON THE GRID MID DAY SO THE
PAPER IS AN HOUR JOHN TO BE
MOVED TO THREE TO EIGHT FOUR
NINE SOMEWHERE THAT TIME FRAME.
I THINK THAT WILL START TO SEND
THE RIGHT PRICE SIGNAL TO
CUSTOMERS.
AND THE OTHER WHICH IS WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK WAS
REFERRING TO ARE THESE WHAT ARE
CALLED NON COINCIDENT DEMAND
CHARGES CHARGING CUSTOMERS FOR
THE HIGHEST USE IT REGARDLESS OF
ONE OF THE CARS.
AND THAT IS.
THAT IS A RATE ELEMENT THAT IS
ACTIVELY UNDER CONSIDERATION AND
YOU SEE OF THE SUBJECT OF OUR A
FORM THAT THEY HAD IN DECEMBER
TO LOOK AT REFORMING NON
RESIDENTIAL RATE DESIGN MORE
BROADLY SO I WOULD EXPECT SOME
MOVEMENT THERE.
TO MOVING AWAY FROM THOSE KINDS
OF DEMAND CHARGES AND PUSHING
MORE THE REVENUE COLLECTION AND
THE PERIOD.
THE NEW PERIOD.
OKAY AND MY SECOND QUESTION IS
DO YOU HAVE DATA ON WHAT.
PERCENTAGE OF ROOFTOP SOLAR.
OUR CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
STORAGE [inaudible]
CAPABILITY.
PRESENTLY AND THEN WHAT IS A
PROJECTED TO BE.
YOU WITH WITH THIS BILL.
WELL CURRENTLY THE THE
PENETRATION OF STORAGE IS STILL
THAT CREDIBLY SMALL THIS IS A
VERY NASCENT INDUSTRY --
AT SEVEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
SOLAR THAT'S NOT EVEN COMPLETELY
INSTALLED INSTALLED AND ARE IN
THE PIPELINE.
VERSUS THOUSANDS OF MEGAWATTS OF
SOLAR INSTALLED PRESENTLY --
SO THE PERCENTAGE OF EXISTING
SYSTEMS WITH STORAGE IS VERY
SMALL.
PROBABLY NOT EVEN 1%.
I'M HEARING FROM SOME MEMBER
COMPANIES THAT THERE AT LEAST IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE
REACHING 20% OF NEW CUSTOMERS.
WHO WERE INSTALLING STORAGE
ALONG WITH THEIR SOLAR SYSTEMS
SO IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE
MARKET IS BEGINNING TO TAKE OFF
BUT IT WILL BE QUITE SOMETIME
BEFORE IT REALLY CATCHES UP TO
THE?
THE SATURATION THAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED WITH ROOFTOP SOLAR.
IS THAT A FUNCTION OF OF COST OF
THE STORAGE SYSTEM PRIMARILY.
IT'S IT'S COST AND THE FACT THAT.
THE THE ENTIRE STORAGE MARKET IN
THE STORAGE TECHNOLOGY IS ABOUT
A DECADE BEHIND SOLAR.
SO I'M IN THE MID TWO THOUSANDS
WHEN THE CSI.
THE CONFERENCE AWARENESS TO
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED FIRST IT
WAS.
TWO THOUSAND SIX IT WAS DESIGNED
TO RUN OR FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WHEN IT TOOK OVER THE
PROGRAM FROM ASCAP --
THAT WAS FROM 200-072-2016.
SO OUR FIRST BEGAN TO TAKE OFF
AROUND 200-082-0009 IF YOU LOOK
AT THE ESTA DATA EVEN THOUGH.
STORAGE WAS ELIGIBLE GOING BACK
TO AROUND TWENTY AROUND AROUND.
TWO THOUSAND NINE TWENTY TEN IT
ONLY BEGAN TO BE INSTALLED IN
ANY MEANINGFUL NUMBERS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT.
THAT RAMP UP TO MARKET MATURITY --
WE WOULDN'T SEE.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THIS BILL THAT WE
NEED THE BILL.
WE NEED TO GET THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SOME IN THAT TIME FRAME. TO
ACHIEVE A REALLY MEANINGFUL
NUMBERS OF OF CUSTOMER CITED
STORAGE.
I JUST ADD ON TO THAT --
THAT SEVEN INJURED MEGAWATTS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE PIPELINE OR
INSTALLED --
ARE PRIMARILY ON A LOT AS A
NONPROFIT AND GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS
I'M PARTICULARS WHERE WE'VE SEEN
A LOT OF STRONG DEMAND SO WERE.
A PARENTAL AT A BENEFITS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE SO
FAR BUT THEY WERE WERE ABOUT
WHERE SALUTE WAS CIRCA TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL SO NEEDED.
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY IT IS OUR GOAL TO
BASICALLY STOP EVERY SOLAR
SYSTEM WITH PAIRED WITH A
BATTERY ONCE WE CAN GET THIS
MARKET OFF THE GROUND THAT THAT
IS THE VISION OF WHERE WE WANT
TO HEAD YEAH IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I IT'S IT'S GOT FASTENING
POTENTIAL BECAUSE I MEAN YOU.
FOR THE TWO HOURS AFTER THE SUN
GOES DOWN I THINK THAT THE DATA
SOMETHING LIKE 36% OF OUR
STATEWIDE ENERGY GRIDS IMPORTED
NASH NATURAL GAS.
OR WHAT IS REFERRED TO SPEAKER
PLANTS OR WHATEVER ELSE AND IF
THERE COULD BE SATURATION ON
STORAGE SO THAT ALL ROOF TOP.
CUSTOMERS ARE STORING ENERGY
PRODUCED WHEN THE SUN'S OUT.
AND DEPLOYING IT DURING THAT TWO
HOUR PERIOD I THOUGHT I SEE
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
THE TRICK TO ME IS THAT HOW DO
YOU.
IF YOU HAVE A SOLAR ARRAY
WITHOUT A STORAGE SYSTEM AND IT
COVERS A HUNDRED AND 10% OF YOUR
HOUSEHOLD NEEDS --
WHAT INCENTIVE DO YOU HAVE TO
BUY THAT EXTRA MODULE?
STORAGE BUT MAYBE THAT'S WHY WE
NEED THE BILL [inaudible]
THERE FAIRPOINT.
YEAH IF I COULD JUST.
YEAH I THINK THERE'S INTEREST
FROM THE CONSUMERS E GOT UP GET
THE MARKET TO MATCH THAT
INTERESTING DRIVE THAT DEMAND
AND IT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DID FOR
SOLAR.
LA AGAIN THE IT WE NEED TO
MOTIVATE CONSUMERS TEND TO OFTEN
OUGHT TO THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS FOR
INTEGRATION OF RENEWABLES.
OKAY I MEAN THE ONLY OTHER POINT
IT OUT.
BECAUSE TO NICE JOB IN ADVOCACY
BUT NO ONE I THINK TOUCHED ON
THE THE EMPLOYMENT ASPECT OF THE
SOLAR INDUSTRY WHICH IS --
YOU KNOW IN MY DISTRICT ALONE
THE NUMBERS I THINK THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PEOPLE ARE
WORKING IN THE SOLAR INDUSTRY IN
SOME CAPACITY OR ANOTHER.
AND THAT'S DIRECTLY IN THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY NOT TO MENTION.
THE FOLKS AT NAY COMMON SERVICE
SAID OR TO OTHER.
GO ANCILLARY THANKS SO.
I'M HAPPY SUPPORT THE BILL JUST
APPRECIATE CENTER BRING IT
FORWARD.
I BUT YOU KNOW THAT.
MAYBE WE CAN TALK OFF LINE YOU
CAN EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THE COST
PIECE IS GOING TO BE ADDRESS
BECAUSE IF IT'S THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR SOMETHING.
STOLEN ARRAY AND THAT COVERS A
100% YOUR HOUSEHOLD NEEDS AND
THAT'S ANOTHER FIVE THOUSAND
IMES MAKING NUMBERS UP IS NUMBER
FIVE THOUSAND TO PUT.
STORAGE UNIT THERE WELL.
WHY ARE YOU GONNA SPEND THIRTY
FIVE IF YOU CAN SPEND?
THIRTY AND IN A SUBSIDY
CERTAINLY CAN PLAY A ROLE I
THINK CAN.
INDUCING THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR
AMONG CUSTOMERS --
BUT IT DOES SEEM TO BE --
A BIT OF A CATCH TWENTY TWO FOR
THE GROWTH POTENTIAL THE
INDUSTRY.
THAT JUST OF A QUICK RESPONSE
ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN THE
PC ISSUED ITS NAME TO POINT OUR
DECISION.
THAT --
IMPLEMENTING AB THREE TWENTY
SEVEN THE THE NEW NAME TARIFF IF
REQUIRED.
CUSTOMERS WANTING DINNER CONNECT
UNDER THEM TARA TO BE ON A TIME
OF USE RATE SO WHAT IS HAPPENING
INCREASINGLY AS THE TIME OF USE
RATES ARE AS THE PEAKS ARE
SHIFTED BACK.
THOSE MIDDAY PRICES ARE PRETTY
LOW.
AND SO IT'S OFTEN A CUSTOMER'S
BENEFIT TO BE ABLE TO ABSORB THE
SOLAR NOT EXPORTED BECAUSE THEY
ONLY GET CREDITED AT THE RATE IN
EFFECT DURING THAT TWO WEEK
PERIOD.
SO THAT SO IT'S ALSO A QUESTION
OF HOW MUCH IS THE POWER WORTH
WHEN IT IS EXPORTED TO THE GRID.
SO YOU WANT TO SAVE IT AND THEN
USE IT DURING THOSE [inaudible]
PEAK HOURS.
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING A LOT OF
THE INTEREST IN STORAGE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS DUCT WORK.
AND FOR MR CUNNINGHAM --
SO I BOUGHT BATTERIES AND THE
OTHER TWO THINGS ONE IS --
WE WON'T HAVE NAM RATES FOR EVER.
AND SO I WAS AS USUAL I WANT TO
GET OUT AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
A BIT BEYOND THAT BY HAVING
BATTERIES SHOULD THERE BE A
POWER FAILURE FOR EARTHQUAKE
WHATEVER REASON YOU'VE GOT POWER --
FOR A GOOD PERIOD OF TIME A FEW
DAYS.
UNTIL HOPEFULLY POWER IS
RESTORED TO THE SEVERAL REASONS
TO GET THEM AND I WAS.
IN LINE TO GET A COUPLE OF
BATTERIES UNDER.
S. CHIP.
SO PEOPLE DO DO IT.
SENATOR WE WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
A WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND AND I'M I'M VERY
PLEASED THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
FIND -- A
PATHWAY --
FOR SB SEVEN HUNDRED I KNOW THAT
IS SO DOUBLE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
SEE AS MANY ON THIS COMMITTEE.
OF THIS AREA YEAH.
GROWN AND TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
IT AND I'M EVEN MORE EFFICIENT
WAY AND TO SEE MORE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF STORAGE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO WE WE'RE
THANKFUL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT.
TO WORK WITH AND TRY TO IDENTIFY
A STRATEGY TO ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN.
AND SO WITH THAT YOU CAN --
VIXEN COMET CICLOS IF YOU'D LIKE
AND I KNOW I I MIGHT ALSO AGAIN
THANK YOU ARE YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
FOR FOR WORKING WITH US I TOOK
AWHILE BUT WE GOT THERE AND I
WAS VERY APPRECIATIVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS.
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
TING PART TING AYE.
OKAY TO PAY THE BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
COLLEAGUES.
NOW WE'RE GONNA OF SEE IF WE CAN
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR NOW
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THERE ARE
THREE OTHER ARE FIVE ITEMS ITEMS.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED [inaudible]
LET ME.
RE READ INTO THE RECORD WHICH
ITEMS ARE ON CONSENT.
ITEMS THREE SB TEN TWENTY EIGHT
HILL ITEM SIX S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX HERTZBERG --
ITEM SEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT HUESO ITEM NINE S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR HUESO WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ITEM TEN SP FOURTEEN TEN MORALE.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
GEN AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
I OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
WELL LET'S MOVE TO ITEM --
TWO S. B. EIGHT NINETEEN HILL.
MOVE THE BELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
THE FIRST THE MOTION THE SECOND.
I AM JUST GOING TO SAY S. B.
EIGHT NINETEEN INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S RATE PAYERS DON'T
PAY FOR UTILITIES NEGLIGENT
BEHAVIOR.
THIS BILL WHICH ACHIEVES THIS
SIMPLY BY CODIFYING EXISTING PC
PRACTICES MANDATING THAT FINES
PENALTIES EXPENSES RESULTING
FROM UNREASONABLE BEHAVIOR NOT
RECOVER ONE RAPES.
I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THINKING FUTURE.
THANKS FOR THAT TO CREATE A
PRESENTATION.
MARK TONY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TURN UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
S. B. EIGHT ONE NINE CODIFIES
INTO LAW A LONG STANDING CP
THREE PRINCIPLE THAT PROHIBITS
CHARGING REPAIRS FOR COUGH
INCURRED TO UNREASONABLE
NEGLIGENT --
OR IMPRUDENT UTILITY BEHAVIOR IN
PLAIN LANGUAGE RATEPAYERS SHOULD
NOT BE MADE TO PAY FOR UTILITY
FAILURE AT OPERATE FACILITIES
AND A FAITH MANNER [inaudible]
I HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
I WILL SAY THAT TURN OF VERY
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT ONE NINE HEARD IT ARE
THERE ANY.
OF ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OR TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT.
ANYONE TO PRESENT AN OPPOSING
POSITION.
SE NON --
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SE NON.
I IS OUR MOTION [inaudible]
HELLO.
SO WE BOTH KNOW THERE WAS ONE
OKAY ALRIGHT.
ALRIGHT OKAY.
CURRENT.
PROGRAM WITH TWICE LURE TOURISTS
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
SENATOR WE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS --
AS IT IS TO PASS TO DO JUST SURE
YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING OR
AND I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH
I APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK OF
YOUR CONSULTANT AND THERE WAS A
A QUESTION RAISED IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS RELATED --
TO LANGUAGE AND WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT LEDGE COUNCIL AND
IN JUDICIARY WE CAN WORK THAT
OUT TO MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR SO I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT WAS
DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT
REACTION AYE VOTE ATTESTED THANK
YOU ROLL CALL PUTS.
HOLDEN HIGH HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
ARE YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
PROBABLY THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT
ITEM.
ARE THE NEXT ITEM I DON'T FOR SP
TWO AND EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR
DODD [inaudible]
BETTER.
WE WE MAY HAVE A FEW PEOPLE WANT
TO SPEAK ON THIS SO WE'RE GONNA
SAY MAYBE TEN MINUTES ON ON EACH
SIDE FOR PRESENTATION.
OKAY THAT WORK YOU'RE THE BOSS
WELL I WANTED TO WORK FOR YOU.
WE GIVE ARE THAT THE CORDOBA
OKAY WE'LL TRY.
TO IF THAT GOAL OKAY SIR.
PLEASE PERSONALLY MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS S. B. TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES TO
PROTECT.
AGAINST DAMAGE FROM STORMS
FLOODS MUD SLIDES EARTHQUAKES
AND WILDFIRES AS WELL AS INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES THAT
WOULD SIXTH SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
THE RISK.
OF IGNITING NEW WILDFIRES S. B.
TENNEY WOULD REQUIRE THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS FOR
UTILITIES TO PROTECT AGAINST
DAMAGE.
FROM A VARIETY OF NATURAL
DISASTERS IT WOULD REQUIRE
UTILITIES TO FILE SAFETY
RELIABILITY RESILIENCY PLANTS
WITH THE CPUC.
PLANNED DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
CORDAY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND FIRE AGENCIES.
ESTABLISHING A LOT STANDALONE
SAFETY PROCEEDING WOULD REQUIRE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN THE
CPU CD GIVE GREATER ATTENTION.
A CARE TO SAFETY AND RELIABILITY.
UTILITIES WOULD BE PROHIBITED
FROM DIVERTING MONEY FROM SAFETY
RELIABILITY RESILIENCE AND
PROHIBITED FROM DELEGATING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IMPLEMENTING
THIS PLANT OTHERS.
THE CPUC WORD REVIEW UTILITIES
COMPLIANCE WITH APPROVED PLANTS
IF HE'D CHILI SUBSTANTIALLY COME.
PLIED WITH ITS PLANNED THE
UTILITY WOULD BE DEEMED TO HAVE
ACTED REASONABLY AND PRUDENTLY.
IF YOU TILL THE FAILED TO
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIED OR
DIVERTED RESOURCES FROM A PLAN
COMPLIANCE IT WOULD BE FAR I'D.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT NOTHING
AN SP TO AND EIGHTY EIGHT SPEAKS
TO OR CHANGES THE LAW PERTAINING
THE LIABILITY OR THE APPLICATION
OF INVERSE CONDEMNATION. TO
UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
HOWEVER THAT CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE CPUC.
THE SUBJECT AT OBJECT
APPLICATIONS FOR RECOVERY OF
COSTS BY INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO A REASONABLE THIS
REVIEW.
S. B. TEN MAYBE IT WOULD MAKE
THE PLANNING AND RATE PROCESS
FOR SAFETY RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCE TRANSPARENT AND
PUBLIC.
MEMBERS IN A WORLD A DRAMATIC
CLIMATE CHANGE WERE WILDFIRE
RATS THREATENS ALL YOUR LONG.
AND WHERE DEVELOPMENT IS PUSHING
FURTHER IN THE HINTERLANDS.
WE MUST REQUIRE UTILITIES TO
MEET THE RESPONSIBILITY TO PRO
ACTIVELY INVEST IN THEIR SYSTEMS
TO MINIMIZE THE POSSIBILITY.
OF IGNITED A YET ANOTHER
DEVASTATING FIRE.
MY CONSTITUENTS WERE DEVASTATED
BY LACKS LAST OCTOBER'S FIRES
DEMAND THAT UTILITIES DO ALL
THEY CAN TO HARDEN THE GRID AND
REDUCE THE POTENTIAL FOR
SPARKING NEW WILDFIRES.
BY REQUIRING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DISASTER RESILIENCY IN
PREVENTION STANDARDS REQUIRE
PLANTS TO MEET THOSE STANDARDS
INVESTING TO ACHIEVE THOSE
STANDARDS AND HOLDING UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE STANDARDS.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD TO
PROTECT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND CONSTITUENTS.
MEMBERS I'M AWARE OF THE
ASSEMBLY HAS A BIPARTISAN WORK
GROUP THAT IS WORKING ON THE
SAME ISSUES THAT S. B.. TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ADDRESSES SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE SIT ON
THAT WORK GROUP I AM ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO COLLABORATING WITH
THE WORK GROUP TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN HARMONIZE.
ALL THE SOLUTIONS TO THE
PROBLEMS AT HAND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UNTIL THE
EMPLOYEES AND OTHER WITNESSES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK JOSEPH
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE EMPLOYEES.
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING BEFORE THE
PC FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
AND EVERYONE OF THOSE YEARS BEEN
INVOLVED AND GENERATE CASES
BEFORE THE COMMISSION.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN THOSE
RATE CASES SAFETY RELIABILITY
GETS VERY LITTLE ATTENTION.
IT'S A BY PRODUCT OF HAGGLING
OVER MONEY IT IS NOT THE FOCUS.
THAT PROCESS HAVE TO CHECK HAS
TO CHANGE IF WE WANT --
A SAFER CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE THAT CHANGE.
THE BILL HAS A TWO STEP PROCESS.
FIRST EVERY OTHER YEAR UTILITIES
WOULD FILE SAFETY RELIABILITY
PLANTS.
WHICH WOULD CONTAIN ALL OF THEIR
PROPOSALS --
FOR MAINTAINING SAFETY
RELIABILITY AND ALL OF THE COSTS
FOR DOING THAT.
YOU'LL BE A PUBLIC PROCESS OF
NOT BE IT APPEARS SEE INSIDER
GAME WOULD BE A PUBLIC PROCESS.
WITH FULL COMPLETE HEARINGS
EVIDENTIARY HEARINGS BRIEFINGS
ARGUMENTS THE WHOLE WORKS.
IF YOU SEE WOULD EVALUATE THE
PLANS WOULD REVISE THE PLANS IF
NEEDED.
AND I WOULD CONSIDER THE COSTS --
THAT IT WANTS TO ALLOCATE TO
THOSE PLANS AND APPROVE THOSE
COST IT IS NOT A BLANK CHECK.
THE PC HAS TO APPROVE EVERY
NICKEL.
AND IT WOULD APPROVE THEM ONLY
OF THOSE COSTS ARE REASONABLE.
IN PARTICULAR SENATOR DODD NOTED
IT WOULD PROHIBIT THE UTILITIES
FROM DIVERTING ANY OF THAT MONEY
TO ANYTHING OTHER THAN THE
SAFETY RELIABILITY PLAN.
THE SECOND STEP IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO IT'S THE
ACCOUNTABILITY STEP [inaudible]
EVERY YEAR.
THE COMMISSION WILL REVIEW WITH
THE UTILITY COMPLIED WITH ITS
PLAN.
IF YES IT WAS THAT WOULD FIND
WAS PRUDENT IF NO THE UTILITY
WILL GET FINED.
NOW THERE ARE SOME WHO CLAIM THE
BILL THE BILL WOULD SOMEHOW
PROTECT THE UTILITY FROM
DISALLOWANCE IS FOR IMPROVEMENTS.
ON THE CONTRARY THAT BUILT
SUBJECTS THE UTILITIES TO FIND
EVERY EAR IF IT FAILS TO FOLLOW
ITS APPROVED PLANT.
IT'S MUCH MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAN WE HAVE RIGHT NOW --
MY COMMENT SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS [inaudible]
ABOUT -- THE
IMPACTS ON RATE PAYERS.
FIRST -- AND
YOU CAN LOOK ON PAGE FOURTEEN
LINES FOUR THROUGH.
SIX THE COMMISSION IS REQUIRED.
TO EXAMINE THE FACTUAL.
AND THAT TO DO A FACTUAL
ANALYSIS OF ANY MAJOR EVENTS.
THAT OCCURRED DURING THE PAST
YEAR.
SO IS NOT A BLANK CHECK BILL BE
CLOSE RUBIO.
AND SECOND AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
[inaudible]
THE COMMISSION.
WE'LL HAVE TO DETERMINE IF ANY
COST IMPOSE AND RATE PAYERS ARE
JUST AND REASONABLE.
IN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
ADDED THAT SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY --
THE COMMISSION'S OBLIGATION TO
MAKE FINDINGS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT WITH RATE PAIR
PROTECTION DUTIES ESTABLISHED
PURSUANT. TO SECTION FOUR FIFTY
ONE OF THE CODE THAT'S ON PAGE
FIND OF PAGE FIFTEEN LINES
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN SO UNDER
THIS BILL RATE PAYERS ARE FULLY
PROTECTED IN EFFECT MORE
PROTECTED THAN CURRENTLY BECAUSE
IT WILL BE SPECIAL PROCEEDINGS.
TO REVIEW THE UTILITIES
PERFORMANCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT WHICH ON
BEHALF THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS OF A FEW
WITNESSES HERE. FOR HANDED OVER
THEM I JUST LIKE TO SAY.
THAT JUST THIS WEEK STANDARD AND
POOR'S [inaudible]
DOWNGRADE UTILITIES.
ALMOST JUNK BOND STATUS.
IT'S BEEN NINE MONTHS SINCE
FIRES AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
PASSED ANYTHING.
WE'RE ON THE PRECIPICE OF A
DISASTER.
THE ONLY POSITIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN MOVING
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AND GIVE ANY.
AMOUNT OF CONFIDENCE TO MARKETS
THAT THE FOLKS ARE PAYING
ATTENTION IS SENATOR DODD'S BILL.
WE NEED THIS BILL TO PASS AS IT
IS.
I ALSO QUALITY ATTENTION TO THE
MEMBERS OF THAT LANGUAGE THAT
MISTER JOSEPH READ WHERE.
ABSOLUTELY UNDERLYING
UNDERSCORED HIGHLIGHTED IN BOLD
THE COMMISSION CANNOT APPROVE
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR RATE PAYER PROTECTION
DUTIES IT DOESN'T GET STRONGER
THAN THAT.
AND WE'D OR DRIVE OUT.
I'M MY NAME IS NAY FAIRMAN I'M
ADJOURNMENT LYMAN AT A SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO THE BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR IBEW LOCAL.
FOUR SIXTY FIVE I REPRESENT
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED MEN
AND WOMEN IN SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES THAT WORK FOR
SINGLE GAS AND ELECTRIC.
AND IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT
AS A GERMAN LYMAN AND BUSINESS
MANAGER REPRESENTED FOR THESE
HARD WORKING UNION UTILITY
WORKERS THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT SAFETY AND THERE'S
NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT IN
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM
ANOTHER DISASTROUS WILDFIRE.
THIS BILL DOES THAT AND WE ARE
VERY VERY STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL.
AGAIN MY NAME IS NAY FAIRMAN THE
BUSINESS MANAGER FOR IBEW LOCAL
FOUR SIXTY FIVE IN SAN DIEGO AND
I REPRESENT TWENTY SEVEN HEART
HUNDRED MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO ARE BEHIND THIS BILL 1100%
THANK YOU?
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS HUNTER STERN I'M WITH
IBEW LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE WE
HAVE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS WORKING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OF APPROXIMATELY TWIRL
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
WORKING FOR P. GENIE --
OUR MEMBERS WORK HARD EVERY DAY
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICAL.
SAFE AND RELIABLE --
SP EIGHT TEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS
WRITTEN.
IS THE BEST WAY TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO MAKE IT SAFE
AND MORE RELIABLE AND MO MORE
RESILIENT TO WILDFIRE AND WE
URGE YOU. TO PASS AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M UP PAT LEVIN IBEW
GERMAN LYMAN CARD NUMBER DE
THREE SIX EIGHT ONE NINE OWN
CASE AND BY ONCE FILE CHARGES ON
ME -- SO I'M
THE BUSINESS MANAGER FINANCIAL
SECRETARY OF I B. W. NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COVERED ALL OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE BUT TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED MEMBERS AT OUR LOCAL
UNION --
THAT'S A LOT OF JOBS.
ALSO IN --
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA I AM THE
IB W. SEVENTH DISTRICT
INTERNATIONAL EXECUTIVE COUNCIL
MEMBER.
REPRESENTED SIXTY FOUR LOCAL
UNIONS OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND IBEW MEMBERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND MOREOVER AND FARTHER BEYOND.
IN A AHUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND TEN WESTERN
UNITED STATES INCLUDING THE
MOUNTAIN STATES --
AS WELL SO.
MANY OF US HERE LIVE THROUGH THE
TEETERING ON THE EDGE OF
DISASTER.
IN AB EIGHTEEN NINETY BACK IN.
THE LATE NINETIES AND EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND WE WATCHED ONE
UTILITY GOING TO BANKRUPTCY AND
WE WATCHED ANOTHER UTILITY
ALMOST THE AND THOSE WERE THE
TWO LARGEST.
UTILITIES AND THE FREE WORLD
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON MPG
IN A AND OUR OUR OUR MEMBERS ALL
OF OUR MEMBERS AND ALL THE
MEMBERS THAT I REPRESENT THOSE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE.
TEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED MEMBERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
IT IS WRITTEN.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO SEE.
THOSE UTILITY COMPANIES
TEETERING AGAIN.
BECAUSE WE ALL REMEMBER OR MOST
OF US REMEMBER.
WHAT THAT WAS LIKE THAT AND THE
AND THE LOSS OF THOSE JOBS?
WOULD BE ANOTHER CATASTROPHE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL HEAR NOW FROM
OTHERS WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
REMEMBER SAYS ON THE OTHER
BEHALF OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
BALLS Y. PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS ON RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROJECTS.
THAT HAVE UP WITH THE UTILITIES
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS THE BILL
AS WRITTEN THANK YOU JUST NAME
IT.
THOUGH IT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO STAND WITH OUR UTILITY
LOCALS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE WORKERS AT
PIGEON <c.green> AND UTILITY WORKERS</c>
UNION OF AMERICA AND SUPPORT.
EMILY I CAME BACK THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS
PATTERSON ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
KEPT HOUSE WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT.
DARREN ABOUT AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
CHARLOTTE STEVENS IBEW TWELVE
FORTY FIVE PASSAGE PASSED THE
BILL AS WRITTEN IN SUPPORT.
ANATHEMA IBEW TWELVE FORTY FIVE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WRITTEN.
HECTOR GONZALEZ IBEW TWELVE
FORTY FIVE IS SUPPORT AS WRITTEN.
RICARDO HERNANDEZ YOU TO THE
WORKING PROUD MEMBER OF IBEW
TOLL FORTY FIVE NOW PLEASE
PASSED THE BILL AS IT.
JOSHUA WELL IN NINETY W. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PASS DOLLARS
WRITTEN THANK YOU.
NANCY MARTINEZ IBEW --
TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS WRITTEN THINK.
GEORGIA CARILLO WITH IBEW TWELVE
FORTY FIVE AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL AS WRITTEN.
I'M SANDY BUSSY IBEW TOLL FORTY
FIVE AND I SUPPORT THE BILL IS
WRITTEN THAT.
I'M HAVING THOUSAND THEY OWN
IBEW TALL FORTY FIVE AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN THANK.
RAMON GONZALEZ IPW TWELVE FORTY
FIVE AND I ALSO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS WRITTEN.
BRIAN HAPPENED TWELVE FORTY FIVE
PM SUPPORT ISRAEL AS WELL.
CORIELL PULL FORTY FIVE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL.
FAQ NOW WILL TAKE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IN MANY TO MAKE SOME ROOM
[inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
TWEENER YEAH.
SIR I JUST.
BUT WHAT DO YOU KNOW WHAT LET
LET.
OUR OUR OUR RECOGNIZE YOU AFTER
WE NOW HEAR FROM THE OPPONENTS
IS RECALLED.
WELCOME AYE MARK TONY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TURN UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK.
WE HAVE TWENTY THOUSAND TO
PAYING MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
TURN OF THE PROPOSED TO F. B..
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT BECAUSE
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLYING WITH THE
PLAN [inaudible]
REPRESENTS LOWERING FAVE
DEFENDERS IT IF NOT THE FAME AS
BEING PRUDENT.
WERE POSTED THE BILL BECAUSE THE
CREATE THE NEW EXPRESS LANE TO
SHIFT THE COST OF MAJOR
DISASTERS TO RATEPAYERS INSTEAD
OF UTILITY SHAREHOLDERS.
CURRENTLY THE CPU THINK CONDUCTS
[inaudible]
BACK THE CIVIC REVIEW OF UTILITY
DISASTER AND IDENTIFIED ON THE
EIGHTH BY CASE BASIS.
ALL INSTANCES IN WHICH THE
UTILITY ACTED PRUDENTLY AND IS
THEREFORE ENTITLED TO REPAIR
RECOVERY AND ALL INSTANCES IN
WHICH THE UTILITY ACTED
IMPRUDENTLY AND SHOULD PAY FOR
DAMAGE INSTEAD OF PASSING IT
RATEPAYERS.
SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT CHANGES THE
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY BY
ELIMINATING THAT FACT DRIVEN
IMPRUDENCE DETERMINATION AND
INSTEAD ONLY F..
IF SO IF A FIFTY PLAN WITH A
POTENTIALLY COMPLIED WITH.
EVEN UP THERE ARE FACTS THAT
INDICATE IMPRUDENCE.
THE BILL EFFECTIVELY FOURTH
SENIOR WORKING FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET PAPER WILDFIRE DAMAGE
AT A TIME WHEN UTILITY SERVICE
IS DISCONNECTED FOR NEARLY ONE
MILLION.
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS EVERY YEAR
WHO FALL BEHIND ON THEIR BILLS.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT FAILED TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL POLICY FOR
ILLUSION THAT ADDRESS THE VERY
REAL CHALLENGES POSED BY
WILDFIRE LIABILITY INVERSE
CONDEMNATION STRICT LIABILITY A
POTENTIALLY CRIPPLING COSTS. TO
UTILITIES AND RATEPAYERS ALIKE I
ASK FOR YOU KNOW VOTE AND
COMMITMENT TO FIX SOLUTIONS.
THAT BRING TOGETHER RATEPAYERS
UTILITIES AND LABOR INSTEAD OF
PROPOSALS THAT TARIFF APART.
RURAL ON BEHALF OF THE AGONY
[inaudible]
ESOS WE REPRESENT A MAJOR
FARMING AND FOOD PROCESSING
OPERATIONS [inaudible] FOR NOW.
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY MARK TONY.
AS IT RELATES TO THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL THE ME
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT RATES
ARE RATES IN CALIFORNIA READY
HIGHER MUCH HIGHER THAN THEY ARE
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE NATION.
ARE FARMERS PAY MORE THAN DOUBLE
WHAT THEY PAY AND MOST OF THE
OTHER AG PRODUCING STATES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE USE A LOT
MORE ENERGY MOVE WATER FOR
FARMING IS GALLAGHER AND OTHERS.
UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FROM A RATE PAYER
IMPLICATIONS STANDPOINT.
AND WE ARE VERY CONCERNED I BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN GENERAL RATE
CASES ON BEHALF OF THE I.
COMMUNITY FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THE PROCESS SET
UP BY THIS BILL DOES IS A
BALANCE PROCESS.
BY THE WAY THIS WORKS IS THE
UTILITIES COME AND WITH A VERY
HIGH NUMBER AND HE'S RIGHT
PROCEEDINGS AND LOOKING TO
COMPROMISE AND REDUCE IT DOWN
AND WE JUST GIVING EXAMPLE.
SOCAL GAS TODAY HAS A 40% GAS
RATE INCREASE PENDING AT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION THE
READ AND DIG INTO THAT RATE CASE
WHAT YOU FIND OUT IT'S ALL
RELATED TO SAFETY FOR ALL THE SO
CANYON.
WE'RE GONNA SEE THE EXACT SAME
SORT OF MASSIVE RATING CREASES
PROPOSED AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE HUGE COST
IMPLICATIONS ON BUSINESSES AND
RICK RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYERS IN
THE STATE AND WE'RE VERY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
I WANT TO POINT TO WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS A VERY GOOD ANALYSIS
THAT WAS DONE BY THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT ITEM SIX IN THAT
ANALYSIS IDENTIFIES ONE OF THE
OTHER CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE.
WHICH IS THE END RUN POTENTIALLY
ON LIABILITY ISSUES WE DISAGREE
THAT THIS WON'T HAVE SOME
IMPLICATIONS AS IT RELATES TO
WHO PAYS.
WE BELIEVE IT DOES HAVE SOME
VERY SERIOUS IMPLICATIONS THAT
NEED FURTHER EXAMINATION AND
THEN FINALLY LET ME JUST MAKE
THE POINT.
THE UTILITIESHAVE A VERY
PERVERSE INCENTIVE TODAY THE
MORE THEY INVEST THE MORE MONEY
THEY MAKE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GUARANTEED
RATE OF RETURN AND SO IF THEY
CAN SHIFT ALL THESE COSTS ON TO
CONSUMERS. TO REDUCE THEIR
LIABILITY THERE'S NO CHECK ON
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO TRY AND
SHUT HIS MUCH UNDER RATEPAYERS.
AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN BECAUSE IT
REDUCES THEIR LIABILITY AND ON
TOP OF THAT TO GET THERE AND A
BIG FAT RATE OF RETURN ON TOP OF
EVERY DIME THEY INVEST SO
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE.
AT ALL FOR THEM TO KEEP THESE
COSTA.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BRISBANE JANA BATH OF KLAY CAN
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS --
REPRESENTING STEEL CEMENT A
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURES PIPELINE
IN WAR.
OUT AGAIN THE ANALYSIS IS IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL DONE IN THE
TIME CONSTRAINTS THE COMPLEXITY.
AND I THINK THE THE GOALS OF
THAT MISTER DODD IS IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IT I THINK ARE CERTAINLY
LAUDABLE.
AND AND WE AGREE SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE WE DO TAKE ISSUE WITH
THE THE STATEMENT THAT NOTHING'S
BEING DONE OR SOMETHING NEEDS TO
BE DONE THAT'S NEW --
THE S. MAP.
AND I AND THE RAMP WHICH TAKE
PLACE IN GENERAL RATE CASES SO
THAT'S THE RISK ASSESSMENT
MITIGATION PHASE IN THE PAST
SAFETY MODELING ASSESSMENT
PROCEEDING IT TAKES PLACE IN THE
GENERATORS.
HOW HAVE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
EVIDENCE AND A HIGHER LEVEL OF
PARTICIPATION BY INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS THIS COMPRESSED
UNREALISTIC EIGHTEEN MONTH TIME
FRAME?
WILL NOT ALLOW FOR THAT SAME
LEVEL OF SCRUTINY.
AND WHAT THE UTILITIES BRING
THEIR RESOURCES COMPARED TO WHAT
WE CANNOT THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
THE TABLE WE GET WHEN WE GET RUN
OVER WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES. TO FIGHT AT THE SAME
LEVEL WITH THE UTILITIES CAN
BRING TO THIS THIS IS WHAT THEY
DO FOR A LIVING.
RIGHT OR JUST TRYING TO KEEP OUR
RATES DOWN SO WE CAN KEEP JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU APARTMENT OTHER
UNCERTAIN IF YOU KNOW WHAT BUT
THE MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
SAW CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I AGREE
WITH YOU KNOW ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE PREVIOUSLY --
IN IN OPPOSITION S. B. TENNEY
WORDS OR ASK EVERYONE TO KNOW.
INDUSTRIAL ELECTRICITY RATES ARE
86% ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WERE WILL ALSO WELL ABOVE TWICE
IN SOME CASES ABOVE THE AVERAGE
OR ABOVE THE RATES.
IN OUR NEIGHBORING STATES SO AS
FAR AS COMPETITIVENESS GOES.
THE IMPACTS TO INDUSTRIAL
ELECTRICAL LITERACY RATES AS
WELL AS RESIDENTS RATES BUT IT
REALLY DOES RAISE SOME
PARTICULAR.
YOU KNOW HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON OUR ABILITY TO CREATE
JOBS MAKE NEW INVESTMENTS A
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S SHOWING IN THOUGH THE
LAGGING INVESTMENT CREATION
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING SECTOR --
RELATIVE TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
NOT THE LAST POINT OUT I WANTED
TO NOTE IS IN ADDITION TO THAT.
IS THAT IS THE PROCESS ISSUE I
THINK MR BOCA DORA MENTION THIS
BRIEFLY.
BUT THE GENERAL RATE CASE
PROCEEDING LOOKS AT THAT ALL OF
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
GENERATION.
A TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
OF ELECTRICITY LOOKS AT THE
SAFETY OR RELIABILITY OF THE
SYSTEM OF THE TO THE RESILIENCE
HE'S LOOKING AT DIFFERENT.
ASPECTS OF AND LOOKING AT ALL
THOSE COSTS TOGETHER.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE WITH
SEGMENTING OUT ALL OF THAT --
THAT THIS ONE IS PARTICULARLY
SHE RELATED TO WILDFIRES AND
OTHER DISASTERS AND AND SAFETY
OPERATIONS AS WELL.
NOW IS THE FACT THAT IT TAKES
ALL OF THE FOCUS AND PUTS IT ON
THAT AND WE BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR A POLITICAL
APPOINTEE ON THE COMMISSION TO
MAKE A DECISION TO NOT SUPPORT.
WHATEVER'S BEFORE THEN BECAUSE
IT IS DEEMED TO BE THIS IS WHAT
IS THIS IS WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR
SAFETY.
SUBDIVIDED FICKLE DECISION TO
MAKE I THINK IT IN IN A PER
INDIVIDUAL IN THAT POSITION.
I IN ADDITION TO THAT IT BECAUSE
IT TAKES ALL OF FOLK THE CONTEXT
OFF OF THE REST THAT --
ALL THE OTHER ISSUES RAISED
REALLY TO THAT BECOMES VERY EASY
TO SAY WELL THAT SOUNDS THAT
SOUNDS APPROPRIATE THAT SOUNDS
REASONABLE WILL THOSE COSTS ARE
GOING TO GET FED INTO THE
GENERAL RATE CASE.
AND WHAT HISTORICALLY WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IS THAT INDUSTRIAL
RATEPAYERS YOU KNOW YOU HAVE --
DID TAKING YOU KNOW INCREASINGLY.
NO SIGNIFICANT INCREASES AS
RESULT OF THE WAY THE P. YOU SEE
IS HANDLED AS WELL SO WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
PROCESS.
THE IMPACTS OF THIS IT CERTAINLY
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
IN DESERVES --
DO ATTENTION AND YOU KNOW THAT
IS IS BEING BROUGHT IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT AREAS I THINK
BRINGING EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW PERHAPS ARE THE
CHAIRMAN'S LEADERSHIP.
FORWARD WE UNFORTUNATELY I DO
NOT SEE S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AS THE RIGHT MOVE AT THIS POINT
TIME.
WELCOME OF THOSE WHO ARE HERE TO
AT THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALICE
KESSLER HERE ON BEHALF OF
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MIKE MATTER COUNSEL FOR CONSUMER
WATCHDOG OPPOSING THE
SOCIALIZATION OF PRIVATE
OPERATIONAL COSTS THINKING.
CHAIR MEMBERS WE SUCH AS WITH
WHAT'S BEEN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE OF THE COMMISSION LARA
KNOW AND HE JACK ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN STATUE GROWERS
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION WESTERN ON
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION.
AND FAR WEST EQUIPMENT DEALERS
IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
POST.
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ IN
BEHALF OF ALSO MAY HAVE TURNED
BUT ALSO BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL MILLER CALVET
ASSOCIATION WINE GRAPE GROWERS
RESPECTFULLY POST.
CAP CAPTAIN IS AT THE END OF US
AS A WE HAVE A THE CALIFORNIA A
MOMS JUSTICE ALLIANCE OFTEN
OPPOSE SPECIFICALLY ON HOW THIS
CAN AFFECT CONSUMERS AND
SPECIFICALLY REPAIRS AND WE DO
AGREE WITH ANALYSIS IN SECTION.
SIX ON HOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
ON THE* LIABILITY.
IT WAS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL IT
ON BEHALF OF THE SNOW WE CAN
AFFORD TO RESIDENTS WRITING COME
UP AT THE END OF SUPPORT THEIR
POSITION CURRENTLY SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENTS THEY SUPPORT
RESILIENCY IN THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE WHAT CENTER TRYING TO
DO.
THEY DO HOWEVER --
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE CCA'S
IN CALIFORNIA ARE HARMED BY THE
BILL SO --
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS FOR THE
CINEMA BOARD THINKING.
THANK YOU CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN POWER
WE ASK OUR MYSTERY OTHERS
COMMENTS THINKING.
MADELINE STENO WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON
GILBERT FOR BECAUSE HE CA WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION.
AND THAT SO FAR DESPITE A GOOD
EFFORT INDEED FROM THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WE DON'T APPEAR TO BE
GETTING THERE AND WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT DOUBLE BILLING
TO SEE CA RATEPAYERS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VIRGINIA FAIR ON THE TINY ON THE
VOLUNTARY WITH OUR ORGANIZATION
HERE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT RP
SUBMITTED A LETTER CONCERNING
THE ISSUES.
AND WHY ARTIST NOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ART STANDS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHOI DEAFENED BAH.
AND I'VE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
LOST THEIR HOME IN THE SANTA
ROSA FIRE.
I'M ALSO A VOLUNTEER FOR A A RP
CALIFORNIA.
AND ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN THIS
STATE.
AARP STRONGLY OPPOSES S. B. TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
P. ANTHONY THOMAS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
AT PRINT SHOP WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
ASKED ME TO ALSO ADD ME. TO TO
THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT --
AS IF YOU AS EVERYONE WHO HAD A
POSITION ON THIS BILL SPOKEN ON
IT.
OKAY THANK YOU WITH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE LET ME
IF I COULD DOCTOR QUIRK BEFORE I
TURN -- TO
TO THE MEMBERS AREA BECAUSE I I
WOULD HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF
RESPECT FOR SENATOR DODD AND
NINE AND WE CERTAINLY --
AGREEMENT MORE TIMES THAN AFFECT
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE LAST TIME
WE DISAGREED BUT I WANTED --
TO TANK YOU FOR AT LEAST --
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH ME ABOUT THE
BILL FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
HIGHLIGHT.
OF SOME OF OF THE CONCERNS AS I
POINTED OUT TO YOU --
I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
CERTAINLY --
IN AND YOUR INTENT LANGUAGE
RECOGNIZING THE IMPACT OF THE
FIRES FROM LAST YEAR AND
CERTAINLY IN YEARS PAST AND WHAT
THAT.
MEANS AND HOW SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT STATION --
WE TRIED TO LOOK AT THE BILL AND
FIND A WAY TO CARVE OUT A SAFETY
BILL --
THERE ARE ELEMENTS TO THIS THAT
REQUIRED QUITE FRANKLY A LOT OF
DETAILED --
REVIEW OF THE WE DIDN'T GO AS
DEEPLY IN SOME AREAS THAT WE
PROBABLY COULD HAVE BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT.
AND TO PRESERVE THE SAFETY
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL CLEARLY --
THE P. YOU SEE THERE MAY BE
ELEMENTS OF YOUR BILL THAT --
COMPLEMENT THEIR PROCESS BUT IT
COULD BE ELEMENTS OF THE BILL
THAT ARE CONTRARY TO THE PROCESS --
WE ARE NOT CLEAR JUST YET ON
WHAT THOSE REPRESENT AND HOW
THEY WOULD BE RECEIVED AND HOW
THEY WOULD BE INTEGRATED INTO
THE CPU.
UC'S.
OUR PROCESS AND REVIEW.
THE OTHER PART IF I COULD --
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'RE WE'RE
ALSO A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE GENERAL RATE CASE --
PROCESS AND HOW THIS IS OUTSIDE
OR DEVIATES FROM THAT EXISTING
PROCESS AND THAT DOES CAUSE SOME
CONCERNS --
BUT HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT
THOSE ELEMENTS WE WERE PREPARED
TO MOVE FORWARD ON BUT THE PART
THAT WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT.
IS THE ELEMENT THAT DEALS WITH
AN ITEM.
SIX THE RATE PAYER VULNERABILITY
AND WHAT THAT COULD ULTIMATELY
MEAN AND HOW IT COULD BE
ULTIMATELY INTERPRETED AND AS
YOU KNOW --
AT LEAST IN THIS HOUSE THIS YEAR
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF EFFORTS TO
LOOK AT FIRE LIABILITY.
AND HOW TO PROPOSE SOME TYPE OF
A SOLUTION A CERTAINLY IN THE
WORKING GROUP THAT WE HAVE BEEN
AFFILIATED WITH.
THERE HAS BEEN NO CONSENSUS ARE
THERE ARE STILL.
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW YOUR BILL
COULD BE --
THAT ISSUE COULD STILL BE
IMPACTED AND FIND ITS WAY INTO
THIS PROCESS AND WE THANK.
AT LEAST THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO STRIKE THE ITEM.
SIX HOW WHICH WOULD THEN GIVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
REVIEW.
OF THE LARGER ISSUES AROUND --
SPREADING COSTS AMONGST
RATEPAYERS AND HOW THAT MIGHT BE
ADDRESSED AND A AND A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY AND AND FAIR
AND EQUITABLE WAY --
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS THE THE
HEART SOUL OF WHY WE MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE DID.
AND SO I'M --
I KNOW THAT IT'S A
RECOMMENDATION.
CORD BUT I HAS YOU SHARED IT
WITH ME I'LL GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS A WHERE THEY'RE
NOT YOU.
YOU --
CONTINUE TO HOLD ON TO THAT
POSITION BUT IT'S MY HOPE THAT.
YOU KNOW.
AND UPON REFLECTION AND ON WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SHARE WITH
YOU TODAY THAT --
YOU WOULD --
EXCEPT THE THE RECOMMENDATION TO
THE LEAD ITEM SIX TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE BILL AS AS
STATED IN PRATT --
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS IN HERE FROM A SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE DE ENERGIZING
CONCEPTS IN A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS AND STRATEGIES THAT I
THINK.
DESERVE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AGAIN.
MAKING IT ABOUT SAFETY AND THAT
WAS OUR INTENT TO SORT OF PUT
THE FOCUS IN THAT AREA.
AND SO I I LAY THAT BEFORE YOU
AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE --
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS PREPARED
MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND MOVE YOUR
BILL ALONG WITH THE AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD STRIKE OF THE ITEM
SIX ON AS ADDRESSES REPAIR
VULNERABILITY.
WELL MISTER CHAIR.
A FIRST OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION --
I SHARE YOUR YOUR FEELINGS AT
THE TOP YOUR CONVERSATION I HAVE
NOTHING BUT RESPECT FOR YOU I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
SOMETHING THAT GOES BEYOND --
GOES BEYOND SAFETY I THINK THE
EASY THING TO DO FOR NOT RIGHT
NOW FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE EASY THING TO DO FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
IS THE POT TO SAFETY --
THIS IS A HARD BILL.
IT'S GIVING YOU ALL A HARD
DECISION BUT IT THAT I MY
PHONE'S BEEN RINGING OFF THE
HOOK AND I'VE HAD PEOPLE.
IN MY OFFICE FOR WEEKS I'VE.
GOD THROUGH THE SAME THING IN
THE SENATE WHEN THE SIMILAR TYPE
OF CONCERNS.
AND NOBODY I HAVE.
AS MANY EGGMAN AMBER'S.
OF MY COMMUNITY WINERIES
THROUGHOUT NAPA AND SONOMA
COUNTY AND FARMS AND SOLANO
COUNTY I'VE AS MANY EGG.
INSTEAD TO ITS AS ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM I HAVE AS MANY
MANUFACTURING.
COMMUNITIES PROPER COMPANIES AS
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM OR CLOSE AND
CERTAINLY.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF A
CONSTITUENTS IT SENATORS AND
MAYBE TWICE AS MANY AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO.
I AM NOT LOOKING FOR SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE
THE RATES AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO
GO HOME. TO MY DISTRICT AND WE
HAVE JUST DONE NOTHING BUT
INCREASED RATES ON MANY FACTORS
INCREASE RATES ON ON HOMER'S
NOTHING.
COULD BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH
BUT BECAUSE THERE IS A FEAR OF
THAT.
ALL THE SUDDEN THERE'S A
DIALOGUE AROUND.
NOT DOING ANYTHING NOT MOVING
FORWARD.
AND AS I SAID BEFORE --
THE ASSEMBLY I MEMBERS THAT ARE
ALREADY WORKING ON THIS I'VE
PLEDGED TO WORK.
I'M NOT SEPARATE WITH THEM IN
CONCERT WITH THEM MOVING
TOGETHER TO GET THE RIGHT
SOLUTION I ALSO --
BELIEVE THAT --
THIS GOES TO THE G. O. COMMITTEE
AND THEN IT GOES TO APPROACH
AFTER SESSION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
TIME -- FOR
ME TO WORK WITH THE CHAIRMAN FOR
ME TO WORK WITH --
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OF IN THE
IN THE ASSEMBLY WORKING GROUP
AND HOPEFULLY --
IN THE SENATE WILL HAVE ONE
THAT'LL AT WORK I WITH YOU AND
HOPEFULLY I'LL BE ON THAT --
BEFORE WHAT RIGHT.
WE COULD HAVE SOME YOU KNOW
ANSWERS TO THESE.
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS SO
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT --
I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE IT
TO HAVE A VOTE ON THE BILL AS
IT'S PROPOSED.
AND WORK WITH THE MEMBERS HERE
AND WORK WITH THE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND AND AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE SOME.
TOUGH CHOICES SO THAT WE CAN
FIND OUT WHAT IT'S GONNA BE IN
MAYBE.
MAYBE IT'S AN OFF RAMP LIKE THE
GOVERNOR HAD ON THEM HAD STILL
ON THE MINIMUM WAGE --
MAYBE THERE'S AN OFF RAMP IF
WHEN HE GETS THE CPUC UP I'VE
GOT SOME IDEAS ON THAT BOBBY
WORKING HAVE TALKED ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW OF A ABOUT THAT SO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT AND LIKE.
TO HAVE AN UP OR DOWN ON THIS
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
APPRECIATE THAT A SENATOR AND
HOW.
SO WITH THAT MY OF MY
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE. TO ARE
ALLOWED TO CARVE THAT PIECE OUT
AND ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN AND
HAPPEN THROUGH OF LEADERSHIP IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PROVIDING
THAT LEADERSHIP AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THIS ISSUE BEFORE THE END
OF SESSION BUT IF IT'S LEFT AND
THAT I WOULD NOT.
BE PREPARED TO SUPPORT.
THE BILL OF TO FORCE TODAY UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH WHERE I'M AT ON
THIS RIGHT NOW IS.
GIVEN THE TIME I BELIEVE THAT IF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE.
HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY OF GOING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE MET A QUICK
DEATH IN APPROPRIATIONS.
ALMOST CERTAINLY IF IT DOESN'T
THERE AND THE GOVERNOR'S GOT ITS
OWN WAY OF DOING IT HE'LL BE
ABLE -- TO
YOU KNOW REJECT THE BILL.
ALL THE RESPECT LIKE THIS SEE A
PROPOSED LAB.
VOTED ON UPPER DOUBTED A I'M
GONNA TURN TO OTHER MEMBERS WERE.
STUCK HERE QUIRK --
BUT FIRST OF ALL I'M GOING.
TO TALK TO THE BILL WITHOUT THE
CHAIRS AMENDMENT.
I SUPPORT THE BILL WITHOUT THE
CHAIRS AMENDMENT --
DISOBEY THE FIRST TIME THIS YEAR
I HAVEN'T SPORTED THE CHAIR AND
I HOPE IT'S THE LAST.
BUT NONE THE LESS I THINK THAT --
THE PART OF THE BILL THE CHAIR
ONCE TAKEN THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT LET ME ADDRESS A FEW
OTHER THINGS FIRST.
ARM WITH THE CHAIRS OUR
PERMISSION.
UP WE HEARD FROM TWELVE FORTY
FIVE THAT THEY ARE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AS WRITTEN MEANING
WITHOUT YOUR AMENDMENT. FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO CAME UP IN SUPPORT.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WHETHER THEY WERE SUPPORTING IT
WITH YOUR AMENDMENT OR WITHOUT --
IS THERE SOME WAY WE CAN FIND
OUT OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN
SUPPORT PERHAPS BY A RAISE OF
HANDS WEB THAT WHICH WAY THEY
WERE SUPPORTING THE BILL WITH
THEIR WITHOUT YOUR AMENDMENT
[inaudible]
BECAUSE THE OKAY SO WELL ASSUME
UNLESS PEOPLE SHOUT OUT
DIFFERENTLY THAT THIS WAS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITHOUT THE
CHAIRS AMENDMENT.
ALL RIGHT --
FIRST OF ALL A INDUSTRIAL
RATEPAYERS DO PAY TOO MUCH AND
LARGE ENERGY USE USED TO PAY TOO
MUCH.
I THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE THING
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT BUT I DON'T
THINK THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT
VEHICLE FOR IT.
I WOULD BE GLAD AND WORKING WITH
OTHERS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
AND SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING WE
BUT I DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO ADDRESS IT BUT
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AND IT
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
OKAY SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
AND I'VE BEEN ON BOTH --
AUTUMN BARRACKS --
BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE I'VE BEEN
ON THE CHAIRS --
COMMITTEE AND WE'VE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND WHAT WE KEEP
ON HEARING.
IS YOU GOT TO DO SOMETHING.
THINGS AREN'T --
SAFE ENOUGH.
RPG AND THE THERE CULPABLE THEY
DIDN'T DO ENOUGH THIS IS WHAT
I'M HEARING OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE PEOPLE
THINK THE MONEY IS COMING FROM
BUT IN THE END IT COMES FROM
RATE PAYERS WATER P. G.'S IN AS
IT ASSETS RIGHT NOW WELL.
LET'S SEE NOW IT CAN'T GET
INSURANCE ANYMORE WITHOUT PAYING
SOMETHING LIKE 33% A YEAR FOR
WHAT THEY UPDATE YET --
WELL THEY HAVE A RETAIL BUSINESS
BUT THAT'S ALL GOING TO THE
CCA'S THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS.
ó THEY HAVE LINES BUT IF YOU
BUY THE LINES YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SUBJECT TO WELCOME --
V. --
INVERSE CONDEMNATION YOU
BASICALLY BECOME THE FIRE ENSURE
FOR THE STATE SURE THEY HAVE
ASSETS NONE OF WHICH YOU WERE
UNFORTUNATELY WORTH VERY MUCH AT
THIS POINT.
AND THE BOND RATING IS IN THE
TOILET SO THEY CAN'T TAKE BONDS.
THIS MONEY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
COME FROM RATEPAYERS THERE IS NO
OTHER WAY TO GET IT AND THAT
DOES MEAN RATES WILL GO UP --
ALREADY WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR THAT HE'S WILLING TO LOOK
AT OFF RAMPS --
THE SECOND THING I WANT.
TO POINT OUT IS THAT.
OUR PEOPLE SAY WE SHOULD KEEP
WITH THE OLD PROCESS.
WELL THERE'S A PROVEN CROSS
SECTION.
COST SAVING IT'S IN THE FINDING
CHAIR IN THE BILL.
I'M THAT YOU GET A LARGE COST
SAVING.
BY IMPROVING THE SYSTEM AND NOT
ALLOWING FIRES.
P. YOU SEE HASN'T DONE THAT --
AS SOMEONE ELSE SAID V. --
ENERGY COMPANIES ASK FOR A LOT
OF MONEY.
OB THEY WANNA FOR EXAMPLE
APPROVE IMPROVE THE SITUATION
AROUND THE NATURAL GAS.
OF FACILITIES AND IMPROVE THE
SAFETY SO WE DON'T GET THE
SMELLY GAS AROUND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO PAY FOR THAT
AND UTILITIES DON'T REALLY HAVE
LARGE ASSETS THAT THEY COULD PAY
FOR IT THEMSELVES IT HAS TO COME
FROM RATEPAYERS.
SO YEAH WE'RE GONNA TO COME FROM
RATEPAYERS.
THE FINAL THING I WANT TO
ADDRESS IS THE AMENDMENT THAT
THE CHAIR TALKED ABOUT.
NO MAYBE THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO
WRITE THIS BUT RIGHT NOW
UTILITIES HAVE NO GUIDELINES.
WHAT WE HEARD FROM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE P. YOU SEE?
ABOUT THE PROCEEDINGS WHILE AND
I ASKED HIM I SAID DOES THIS
MEAN IN THE PROCEEDINGS ARE
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT.
HE SAID YES [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT
BELIEVE ME YOU WILL NEVER BE
FOUND INNOCENT.
ARE IN THE CASE OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS OF CHEESE ME
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ELECTRIC.
THERE WAS AN OPERATOR ON THE
LINES WITH MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WHO DECIDED NOT TO DE
ENERGIZE A LINE.
COMMISSIONERS VOTED FIVE ZERO
THAT HE SHOULD HAVE DE ENERGIZE
THE LINE TO SEE IF THEY KNEW
WHAT THE HELL THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND AGAIN I'VE HEARD FOR
THE COMMISSION IS THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW.
WHETHER OR NOT HE SHOULD HAVE DE
ENERGIZED THE LINE BUT THAT'S
WHAT THE PRECEDING SAID THERE
ARE NO STANDARDS.
NOW I THINK YOU KNOW WE CAN
ARGUE ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS THE
EXACT RIGHT STANDARD --
WE CAN WE CAN FIDDLE WITH SOME
OF THE WORDING BUT THERE HAS TO
BE A STANDARD.
I CAN'T JUST SAY O. P. GENIE I
KNOW YOU TRIM THE MILLION AND A
HALF TREES BUT YOU SHOULD HAVE
TRIMMED A MILLION AND A HALF AND
THREE AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
CHARGE YOU TEN BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH BY THE WAY.
P. GENIE DOESN'T HAVE.
THEMOST LIKELY --
SCENARIO IS IF WE GO AHEAD WITH
THE INVERSE CONDEMNATION AND WE
FIND THE AND THIS BILL HAS BY
THE WAY NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
LAST FIRE THIS IS GOING AHEAD.
THE MOST LIKELY THING IS P.
JEANNIE GOES BANKRUPTCY WHICH IS
GOOD FOR PGM EIGHT LOOK AT HOW
WELL THEY DID THE LAST TIME.
BUT ALSO LOOK LOOK WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE WORKERS IN THE RATE
PAYERS.
LAST TIME WHEN THEY WENT WE ARE
STILL PAYING A LARGE BILL
BECAUSE P. JEANNIE WENT BANKRUPT.
WE ARE STILL PAYING A LARGE BILL
BECAUSE THE STATE TOOK OVER FROM
THE ENERGY COMPANIES WHEN THEY
COULDN'T BUY POWER ANYMORE.
AND THAT WAS A BIG MISTAKE.
SO HERE WE'RE TRYING TO SET UP A
STANDARD --
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THAT STANDARD --
SO WE NEED TO HAVE THAT POLICY
WE NEED PEOPLE TO KNOW WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
IF THERE IS NO STANDARD.
FAT AND THIRD YEARS YES BEING
WHAT IT IS.
THEY SHOULD DO AND THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW THAT SOME PEOPLE
WANT TO CONTINUE HAPPENING WE
HAVE A PROCEEDING WHERE THE
MONEY DOESN'T GET ASIDE. FOR
WHERE THE MONEY IS TO PUT ASIDE
FOR SAFETY WE HAVE A WAY THAT
THE UTILITIES HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
IT IS THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A GOOD
SYSTEM.
ALRIGHT I AM NOW GOING TO MOVE
THE BELL AS WRITTEN WITHOUT THE
CHAIR WITH DUE RESPECT FOR THE
CHAIR OF THE HELP I CAN READ
SUPPORT OF EVERY OTHER TIME THIS
YEAR.
BUT WITH THAT WITH DUE RESPECT
FOR THE CHAIR I SEE I MOVE THE
BILL WITHOUT THE CHAIRS
AMENDMENT.
I'LL TAKE TWO DIVERSIONS FROM MA --
MY MY FRIEND MISTER QUIRK I HAVE
NOT ALWAYS AGREED WITH THE CHAIR
AND I WILL BE BRIEF [inaudible]
OF A BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S ALREADY BEEN WORKED
OUT THAT SHE DIDN'T HAVE THE THE
VOTES -- BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR A LONG
TIME I THINK WE NEED A GRANDER
PLAN.
RIGHT AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IS A PIECE OF THAT
GRANDER PLAN BUT IT IS NOT
ENCOMPASSING ASSEMBLY WHO
REPRESENTS AN AREA THAT'S GONNA
BE HUNDRED EIGHT THIS WEEKEND.
WE ALREADY HAVE EXTRAORDINARILY
COSTS OF ABOUT OF ENERGY
ASSEMBLY WHO REPRESENTS AN AREA
WHERE WE STILL PROCESS FOOD AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF BAG AND WE KNOW.
THAT OUR WE HAVE OUR OUR
AGRICULTURE ECONOMY HAS BEEN.
OUT OF HAS BEEN UNDER FIRE FOR
AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN HERE AND
AND BEFORE AND THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE --
DE THEN THE DOWNWARD.
PORTION ON IT --
AS FAR AS ENERGY RATES AND I
HAVE USED A AND I AND I WILL USE
THE SAME ANALOGY KEEP USING OF
CRAP BUT AS A SOCIAL WORKER.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENS.
THE SUMMARY IS GONNA COMMIT
SUICIDE.
I DO A SAFETY PLAN.
I DISCIPLINE TO KEEP THEIR
PERSONAL LIFE THAT I THINK I
PRAYER WENT UP GOOD GOOD GOOD
GOOD.
THEY DO EVERYTHING I ASK.
AND YET THE END THEY STILL END
UP [inaudible]
FOLLOWING THROUGH.
WHEN WE PUT IN SAFETY PLANS THEY
ARE ONLY I MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE
SOMETHING WE THINK ABOUT IN THE
MOMENT?
BUT AS FAR AS THE GRAND IMPACT
OF WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
THERE'S NO PLANNING WE CAN DO
ECONOMICALLY ADDRESS ALL OF THAT
WITHOUT.
OTHER FACTORS INVOLVED TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE.
THE PLANS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE.
WE ALREADY HAVE MULTIPLE PLANT A
SEED CBB IT P. UC IS WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW I THINK THIS PUTS A
REALLY EXPEDITED WAY AND
CERTAINLY ANYTHING WE KNOW.
IS THAT WE DON'T MOVE VERY
QUICKLY AROUND HERE.
THAT NOW WE'RE ASKING EVERYTHING
TO HAPPEN WITHIN APPEARED
EIGHTEEN MONTHS I ALSO DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I AGAIN I KEEP HEARING ABOUT A
GRANDER PLAN IS COMING TOGETHER
I HOPE THAT HAPPENS AND I HOPE
THAT I WILL BE ABLE SUPPORT WHEN
WE GET THERE.
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE OUR
UTILITY WORKERS WORKING WE NEED
TO HAVE --
DE RELIABLE POWER AND WE NEED TO
HAVE THE SAFETY AND WE'RE COMING
BACK INTO WILDFIRE SEASON AGAIN.
SO BUT STILL CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TO GET THIS JOB DONE.
AND I AND I CERTAINLY HOPE WE
GET THERE BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATIVE SEASON IS OVER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF A
FIRST OF ALL I WANNA ECHO
APPRECIATION --
OF THE CHAIR AND WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR AND I I REALLY I
REALLY.
A HONESTLY --
WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR AN AWFUL
LOT OF HARD WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING UP TOGETHER --
SECONDLY OF SOMETIMES I THINK WE
WE THINK WE KNOW SO MUCH FOR SO.
CERTAIN.
WHEN WE REALLY DON'T?
AND THAT'S WHY I'M.
A INCLINED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AS WRITTEN [inaudible]
AND TAKE THE CHAIR PARA.
UP AND TO CHECK TAKE MR DOT UP --
ON THEIR COMMITMENTS AND
PROMISES TO WORK THROUGH THIS
WITH AN EYE TOWARD WHAT THIS
DOES. TO RATE PAYERS
[inaudible]
AND THIRDLY.
WE ARE ACTUALLY HAVING THE
BEGINNINGS OF THAT BIGGER.
SURE CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW.
AND I AM CONCERNED THAT THE
CLOCK IS TICKING.
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT JUST DOING
SOMETHING.
BUT IT IS ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
THAT WORKS DOING SOMETHING THAT
IS FAIR AND REASONABLE.
AND OING SOMETHING THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT THE THAT MOTHER
NATURE AND THE WILDFIRES IN THE
PLACE WE ARE IN TODAY HAS DEALT
US A HORRIBLE SET OF PLAYING
CARDS [inaudible]
AFFECTING EVERYBODY AND THE
SUREST WAY FOR US. TO GET OUT
FROM UNDERNEATH THIS THERE'S
THIS HORRIBLE --
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES IS TO TRY
EVERYTHING WE KNOW HOW TO DRIVE
THESE RISKS DOWN.
BY MANAGING THE FORCE BETTER BY
SAFETY PLANTS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD BY HOLDING THE UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE
[inaudible]
SAFETY PLANTS.
AND SO FOR A LOT OF REASONS --
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS MOVE
FORWARD.
AND I ALSO --
DO WANT TO REITERATE THOUGH AND
AS I'VE MENTIONED TO US.
THE MANUFACTURERS AND TO
AGRICULTURE --
RATES AND WHAT RATES ARE DOING
AT THE AGRICULTURE AND AND
MANUFACTURING IS IS --
IT'S TERRIBLE.
AND YET IT IT IT HAS THE IT I
DON'T THINK IT IS RESIDENT IN
THIS BILL.
ON I THINK WHAT HAS CAUSED THE
PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN POLICIES OF
COME OUT OF THIS PLACE ANOTHER
BILLS AND OTHER --
EFFORTS THAT HAVE JUST BASICALLY
SAID YOU GOT THE DEEP POCKETS
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
SHIFT THAT TO YOU.
SO FOR A LOT OF REASONS I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD STEP FORWARD.
AND I HOPE THAT IT DEMONSTRATES
A WILLINGNESS TO MOVE BEYOND
JUST THE MEETINGS IN THE
DISCUSSIONS.
AND TOWARD GETTING THE
ADMINISTRATION GETTING OUR
COMMIT WORKING GROUP GETTING
THAT MEMBER BURKE WORKING GROUP
TOGETHER WORKING THROUGH TO GET
TO THESE KINDS OF SOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
WE'D WE DON'T HAVE THE CHOICE
OF DECIDING ON SOMETHING PERFECT.
BUT WE DO HAVE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE A
DECISION ON SOMETHING THAT WILL
MOVE FORWARD OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AS ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES. TO
DEAL WITH THE OVER ARCHING
PROBLEM OF WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THESE FIRES.
AND I THINK THIS IS A A GOOD
DECENT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT RATES
AND I'M GOING TO CONTINUE.
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE MEN AS
THE PROCESS MOVES FORWARD AND AS
WE TALK ABOUT THIS IN A BIGGER.
ABOUT PICTURE AND GET TO THAT TO
THE TO THE BIG LOOK.
OF THAT I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO BE
THERE ON BEHALF OF THOSE THAT I
THINK ARE --
UNFORTUNATELY MISTREATED BY SOME
OF THE OTHER POLICIES THAT HAVE
COME TO THIS BUILDING.
FIGURES CHAIR.
A SENATOR.
AFTER THE FIRES THAT OCCURRED --
LAST YEAR I MEMBERS A FEW WEEKS --
SEEING YOU DOWNTURN EVENT DOWN
IN SOUTHERN CAL AND IT'S THE
MEMBERS SEEM EMOTION --
IT IN YOUR EYES A FROM PEOPLE
THAT YOU HAD KNOWN WHO LOST A
THAT EVERYTHING I'M FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES --
THIS IS A BILL THAT'S DIFFICULT
AND YOU DIDN'T TAKE THE EASY WAY
OUT AND JUST DO.
A POLITICAL SHOWMANSHIP VALUE
ACTUALLY DUG AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE THE OVERALL PROBLEM
YOU'RE TO BE COMMENDED OF FOR
THAT -- I AM
WELL ON ON BOTH WORKING GROUPS
AND I'VE SPENT A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME ON THIS OVERALL
QUESTION OF WHAT WE DO.
ABOUT STRICT LIABILITY IN THE
RISKS -- TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE --
A SECURE ENERGY SYSTEM HERE IN
THE IN THE STATE AND THE
PROBLEMS ARE --
ARE GREAT OF THE SOLUTIONS SO WE
DON'T HAVE ONE YET FACT THE ONLY
ONE THAT WE DO HAVE TODAY.
IS IN THIS BILL AND IF WE
ELIMINATE --
THAT LANGUAGE AND ITEM NUMBER
SIX THEM THERE'S REALLY NO POINT
WE ARE SAYING WE DON'T HAVE --
ANY SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY SOLUTION BUT IT
IS A PIECE.
OF THE PUZZLE AND SO I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP WORKING WITH
YOU.
I'M I THINK THIS IS FANTASTIC
WORK IT'S NOT PERFECT OF COURSE
AB LET'S CONTINUE TO KEEP
WORKING TOGETHER AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT --
TODAY.
AWAKE AT HEARING KNOW OTHERS WHO
LIKE TO TO SPEAK ON THE ISSUE
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
DON'T THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NAPA A FOR FOR TAKING ON THIS
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW THE SECOND
THOSE COMMENTS THAT --
YOU KNOW.
IT THIS IS A TOUGH ISSUE --
AND YOU KNOW AS A AS
REPRESENTATIVE WHO CAME WHO
COMES FROM THE DISTRICT THAT HAD
FIRES RAVAGE THROUGH.
MY COMMUNITIES --
YEAH WE CAN'T JUST IGNORE THIS
WE GOT IT WE GOTTA TAKE THIS ON
NEON SOMEBODY WHO ALSO
REPRESENTS OROVILLE DAM IN AND
SAW WHAT WE WENT THROUGH THERE.
A WITH THAT NEAR DISASTER --
WAS THE IMPETUS FOR A SAY WE
NEED TO DO BETTER FROM A SAFETY
STANDPOINT WE NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND OUR PLANS --
AND SO I VERY MUCH HE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF RABBIT TRAILS --
YOU KNOW IN THIS DISCUSSION BUT
I THINK THE HEART OF YOUR BILL
IS ABOUT.
RAISING THE BAR --
FOR SAFETY THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THERE'S DEFICIENCIES OUT THERE.
BOB AND IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT
A DEFINITE STANDARD --
A SAFETY STANDARD TIME FOR
BEFORE I USE.
AND SO KNOW WE NEED TO DO THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A COST TO
DO IT.
THERE'S A COST TO DOING WHAT IT
TAKES TO IMPROVE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE MAKE IT SAFER.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD BE
BORNE BY RATE PAYERS ALONE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT YOUR
INTENT.
THAT AND AND AND I DON'T THINK
THE BILL EVEN SAYS THAT SO --
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
TO STILL REMAIN TO BE WORKING
NOT WORKED ON NO GOING FORWARD I
GUESS MY TWO BIG CONCERNS WOULD
BE I THINK WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT
WHAT A SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
WAS THAT MEAN LET'S.
LET'S DEFINE WHAT THAT MEANS OR
MAYBE JUST SAY COMPLIANCE VIA
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PLAN --
SHOWS THAT YOU'RE PRUDENT --
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER PART
WOULD BE IN AND AND PERHAPS
SOMEONE CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION
IS -- NEAR
AYE I HEAR THE COMPLAINTS FROM
FROM THE OPPOSITION --
THAT THIS MAYBE SETS UP A NEW --
PROCESS RIGHT THAT COULD BE
MAYBE MAYBE THIS PROCESS COULD
BE PUT INTO THE GENERAL RATE
MAKING PROCESS OR OTHER SAFETY
PROCESS HE'S THAT --
ARTIGO THROUGH THE PC. TO AVOID
TO AVOID SORT OF DUPLICATION OR
DIEM MAYBE MORE COSTLY --
PROCESS HE'S TO THE PC.
ARE NOT UP THAT'S IS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT JUST CAME
[inaudible]
ROUTE -- FOR
YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES --
YOU KNOW IF THIS BILL MOVES FOR
TODAY.
WHAT WE'RE OPEN TO THAT SEVEN
MEMBER?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I SPECTER THE CENTER'S WORK --
TO ADDRESS.
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT --
YOUR DISTRICT HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE HARDEST HIT.
WITH THAT MANY OF THESE ISSUES --
BUT I AS FOR AS THE BEING THERE
PRESENTED WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS
I CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
I HEAR WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING
ABOUT HOW WE CANNOT DO.
WE WE WE CANNOT STAND BY AND DO
NOTHING.
BUT WE ARE DOING SOMETHING HERE
BY [inaudible]
VOTING.
ON THIS BILL TODAY [inaudible]
AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR.
THAT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT. TO BE
UTILITIES AND TO ALL THE
ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
MY PROBLEM IS WITH THIS.
ALMOST BLANK CHECK THAT WE'RE
PASSING. TO PASS THE COSTS.
ONTO RATE PAYERS.
THE TERM LETTER ON PAGE.
TWO INDICATES THAT UNDER THE
PROPOSED.
PC SECTION A UTILITY IN
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
PLAN.
WOULD BE INSULATED FROM A
FINDING OF IMPRUDENCE EVEN IF
UTILITY NEGLIGENCE COST A WAD
FAR OF THE DISASTER.
I THINK AS A MATTER OF
INTERPRETATION I THINK IT'S A AS
POINTED OUT IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
WHEN THE UTILITY?
THEN AND CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
BUT I'M READING FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES THE WHEN THE
UTILITIES.
ISN'T SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE.
WHAT'S WITH FILED AND IMPROVE
SAFETY RELIABILITY RESILIENCE
PLAN.
THAT THEY WOULD BE OF THE PASS
ON THE COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
[inaudible]
AND SO.
LIKE WITH ANY COMPLICATED
PROCESS WE NEED TO HAVE DUE
PROCESS WE NEED TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STAKEHOLDERS.
TO BE OF THE WAY AND BEFORE THE
COSTS ARE PASSED ON TO
RATEPAYERS AND SO.
I'M AFRAID THAT WE ARE MAKING.
A BAD SITUATION EVEN WORSE.
BY PASSING THIS BILL ALONG.
AND FOR THAT REASON.
I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
[inaudible]
SHOOTING.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA
ECHO NAM MISTER COURSE COMMENTS
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THOUGH LE UN I'VE DISCREETLY
COMMITTED I HOPE IT'LL BE THE
LAST TIME AS WELL.
I I DO FEEL ON THAT ONE OF THEIR
COMPLAINTS THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HAD.
HAS BEEN REALLY THE BEHAVIOR ALL
THE REGULATORS AS WELL AS ALL
THE DIFFERENT ILLUSTRATIVE
AGENCIES.
I OFTENTIMES MANY PEOPLE ON
DIFFERENT SIDES --
DISCUSS SORT OF FIVE AND TPC
OVERSTEPPING THAT'S BEEN ONE OF
MY COMPLAINTS IN THE PAST.
BUT IF THE LEGISLATURE IF WE AS
A GOVERNMENT DON'T GIVE THE CPUC
DIRECTION THEN [inaudible]
THE THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
TO PROVIDE THEM DIRECTION THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE.
DIRECTION HAS BEEN REQUESTED BY
THE COMMISSIONERS.
AND THAT --
THIS IS THE DIRECTION THE
SENATOR --
FROM NAPA HAS PROVIDED AYE BUT I
BELIEVE IT'S A SENSIBLE PLAN I
THINK IT'S A PRUDENT PLAN I
DON'T THINK IT OVER STEPS.
I THINK I THINK HE'S COMPLETELY
CORRECT THAT SHOULD WE HAVE --
A BROADER PLAN IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS BEFORE END OF
SESSION.
THAT HIS BILL ARE CAN BE
INCORPORATOR THE IDEAS HERE CAN
BE INCORPORATED IN SOME.
SORT OF LARGER PROGRAMS I THINK
IT IS.
THAT WE SEE AS A LEGISLATURE
THAT WE WE LEGISLATE AND PROVIDE
THAT DIRECTION TO THE CPUC.
AYE AND THAT THEY DON'T JUST GET
TO DECIDE. TO DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT HOWEVER THEY WANT WHENEVER
THEY WANT --
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE CORE
CROCKS OF THE OF THE BILL DOES
COME IN TWO PARTS WHERE.
WE HAVE A PLAN.
THE PLANS AGREED UPON WITH THE
REGULATE REGULATOR BUT IF.
THE PLAN HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IF
THE PLAN IS BEING CARRIED OUT
THAT THERE IS SOME LEVEL OF
RECOURSE FOR FOR THE DELAY SO I
THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IF YOU HAVE A PLAN.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE ANY RECOURSE
AT THE END I THINK THE PLAN IN
OF ITSELF.
ISN'T REALLY USE FOR ANYTHING
DOESN'T REALLY PROVIDE ANY
DIRECTION JUST BECOMES JUST
ANOTHER.
PIECE OF PAPER TO SIT ON TOP OF
PILES OF PIECE OF PAPER OVER THE
CPUC.
THE SO SO THAT IS WHY TODAY AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT IS
A GOOD FIRST STEP INTO WHAT IS --
WHAT IS OCCURRING --
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PROVIDE THAT DIRECTION TO THIS
COMMISSION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS OF I
THINK IT'S SENATOR DODD.
YOU -- HAVE
AS I INDICATED EARLIER ON TAKEN
ON THE ISSUE AND YOU'VE
CERTAINLY BEEN VERY --
THOUGHTFUL IN YOUR APPROACH --
I'VE HIGHLIGHTED SCENARIOS THAT
I THINK THIS COMMITTEE --
NEEDS TO BE PRUDENT ON AND NEED
TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND HOW WE
EVALUATE ALL BILLS THAT COME
FORTH ESPECIALLY IN THE LARGER
CONTEXT AND I KNOW THAT --
IT IS --
EVERYONE'S EXPECTATION HOPE THAT
THE FOCUS OBVIOUSLY IS ON HAVING
A CLEAR CONCISE STRATEGY OF HOW
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF SAFETY --
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THE LARGER
CONTEXT OR OTHER.
OUR CONVERSATIONS AND OTHER
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE.
A FINE POINT PUT ON THEM --
MY HOPE TO HAVE IT IN MORE OF A
PIECEMEAL FASHION.
AND I THINK THAT WE HOPEFULLY WE
WILL GET THERE BEFORE THE END OF
THE SESSION --
BUT IN --
UNDERSTANDING THAT --
ADDRESSING AN ISSUE OF THIS
MAGNITUDE AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED.
OF FIRST STEP IS BETTER THAN NO
STEP I THINK THAT.
IT DEPENDS ON IF YOU'RE ON THE
EDGE OF A CLIFF.
AND SO IF YOU TAKE THAT NEXT
STEP.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S ONE STEP.
THAT COULD BE A DEADLY STEP.
S. SO -- LET
ME JUST SAY THAT --
IT APPEARS THAT YOU HAVE SUPPORT.
TO KEEP YOUR CONCEPT MOVING I
WILL GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SOME CLOSING THOUGHTS AND
THEN WILL.
CALL THE ROLL.
I APPRECIATE MISTER CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE --
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU IF THAT'S STILL BILL DOES
MOVE BECAUSE YOU GET A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA AND LIKE
TO WORK WITH THE TO SANTORUM A
MERE SU CHI'S --
POINT SECTION.
FOR FIFTY ONE IN THIS BILL --
ONE THAT WILL NOT ALLOW.
I DID DOES IT DOESN'T MANDATE
THAT BECAUSE MY BUT THIS THIS
BILL SETS --
FOR REASONABLE THAT'S STATURE
DEAD.
THEY STILL HAVE THE ULTIMATE
DISCRETION.
ON ON RATE SETTING THE OTHER
THING IS THIS COMMITTEE JUST
PASSED SENATOR HILLS BILL
[inaudible]
WHICH SAYS --
THAT -- IF
THERE'S NEGLIGENCE BY THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY THE
RATEPAYERS WILL NOT PAGE.
AND I TOTALLY AGREE.
WITH WHO YOU KNOW WITH THAT
SENTIMENT WITHOUT POLICY IN FACT
I'M A CO AUTHOR.
ON SENATOR HILLS BILL I THINK
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THE ACCOLADES --
ON MY DISTRICT AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT GOT FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS.
THIS IS NO LONGER ABOUT MY
DISTRICT.
IT'S OVER THERE THERE'S PAIN
THEIR SUFFERING THIS ABOUT YOURS
SOME OF YOUR DISTRICTS IN THE
FOR IF YOU'RE IN THE VALLEY AND
YOU HAVE SOME FOOT HILLS.
LET ME TELL YOU CENTER GALLAGHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU
POINTED OUT OF THIS FIRE DOES IT
NO WAY.
SENATE DISTRICTS IT DOESN'T KNOW
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS WE NEED TO
GET A MORE RESILIENT GRAD IN THE
FUTURE.
AND THAT WE ALSO NEED TO BE ABLE
TO FIND WAYS TO BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR THIS IS THAT START I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
AMOUNT OF CLERK TALK CULTURAL.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHTH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE HOLDEN --
NO HOLDEN NO.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PATTERSON I FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI NOT BAD.
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE REYES.
REYES NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
NOW YOU HAVE EIGHT VOTES YOUR
BILL ITSELF AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN THING WORST CHAIRMAN
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD -- WE
HAVE SENATOR BRADFORD --
HERE FOR S. B. [inaudible]
ELEVEN TEN I KNOW.
YOU DON'T LIKE.
SENATOR WELCOME YOU ARE
[inaudible]
IT.
AFTER I VOTE.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT KIND OF
MAGIC YOU'RE WORKING WITH.
A ONE OF MY DIG IT BUT IT BUT IN
SHORT I THINK OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE I'M JUST I'M JUST HERE TO
PRESENT AYE AS BE ELEVEN TEN
WHICH IS STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE.
THAT IS ADDRESSING --
SOME THE POWER PLANTS THAT WERE
BUILT IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND ONE DURING THE ENERGY
CRISIS WHEN A LOT OF MINUTES BOW
OUR GOVERNMENT'S TICKET UPON
THEMSELVES WHEN THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
ARE EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO --
COULDN'T ON BIGGER THE SIT
SITUATION OUT IN OUR INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WERE IN A CRISIS
AND WE COULDN'T SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS AND NOW MANY OF THEM
ARE LEFT WITH THAT STRANDED DEBT
AND ALL THIS IS.
SAN IS ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AT 20% CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THEIR BASE LOW
CUSTOMERS AND HELP ALLEVIATE
THAT DEBT GOING FOR AND VOTE IN
WITH YOUR WITH ME IS GREAT COOK
FROM THE NORDIC NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWERS AGENCY.
IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS VERY BRIEF
THIS IMPORTANT BUILT A THREE
UTILITIES AND OTHER IN
CALIFORNIA WHO RESPONDED TO THE
ENERGY CRISIS OF TWO THOUSAND
TWO THOUSAND ONE BY ASSURING
RELIABILITY IN BUILDING.
BUILDING ELECTRICITY PLANTS.
THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM
WILL.
KICK IN WHEN THE A 50% RENEWABLE
REQUIREMENT INCREASES AND WILL
GO AWAY WITH THE DAY THOSE.
BONDS TO PAY --
FOR DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M PARA KEENER WITH
THE CITY REDDING REDDING
ELECTRIC UTILITY APPRECIATE
BEING HERE MAKE YOU JUST A FEW
COMMENTS.
CHAIRMAN.
APPRECIATE CENTER BRADFORD TO
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL.
OF ALMOST EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO
BECAUSE OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETY A
LOT OF UTILITIES WERE LEFT OF
HOLDING THE BAG AND SOME OF US
MOVE FORWARD AND SPEND MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BUILD
OUR OWN POWER PLANTS.
IN ORDER FOR US TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY.
AND BEING ABLE TO KEEP OUR
LIGHTS ON WE HAVE BEEN A
PROPONENT OF RENEWABLE POWER.
ALL WE ARE STAYING.
WITH THE STANDARDS THAT ARE IN
PLACE TODAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING.
OUT IN THE FUTURE AS OUR PS
MOVES FORWARD BUT E NEED SOME
HELP RELIEF WITH THE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
SPENT WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIX MILLION DOLLARS LEFT TO
DEBT.
THE DEBT WILL BE PAID OFF BY.
TWENTY FOR AN AYE VOTE --
FAQ ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
I JOIN AND WITH --
SUPPORTIVE COMMENT.
OKAY WILL ENTERTAIN OF THOSE WHO
ARE HERE AS WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AS THE OTHER
ANY COMMENTS.
ARE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
CNN THERE'S A MOTION IN FRONT OF
US.
AND I WOULD GO ON RECORD MISTER
CHAIRMAN EXCEPT THE MOMENTUM
GOING TO CONTINUE WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE AS WE MOVE TOWARD HER.
OKAY LIKE A BECAUSE AS A CLOSE
INCOME YES THANK YOU VERY VOCAL
ON MARS.
AND THIS IS A A MOTION --
DO PASSED --
TO NET TO RESOURCES.
HOLDEN BY HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN.
GEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I IN ORDER GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
REFUGEE AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
THE BILL IS OUT BANK REGULATIONS
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN LANCASTER
MEMBERS WE SHOULD THANK YOU --
IS SENATOR SKINNER.
SHE'S ON HER WAY OKAY WE'LL TAKE
A BRIEF PAUSE THE TO SHE GETS
HERE
.
FOCUS SENATOR SKINNER.
YEAH WE'RE READY.
TO KEEP --
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN NINE FIRST OFF
I WILL TAKE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AND THANK YOU AND THAT IT'S A
GOOD BILL SO I CAN GO TO THE
DETAILS OR YOU KNOW YOU'VE HAD A
LONG DAY --
IT ALLOWS US TO USE OUR MILITARY.
USE YOU ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU ON YOUR WAS SFI THEM
THERE IS A SLIGHT MODIFICATION I
THINK THAT.
WELL THIS IS WHAT I UNDERSTAND
AND ALL SAY THEM AND THEN YOU
CAN LET ME KNOW.
THAT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WILL CLARIFY THE PURPOSE OF THE
PILOT.
WILL CLARIFY THE FUNDING SOURCE
SORTS EPIC UNTIL WE SECURE OR
UNLESS WE SECURE A ARE THE
FUNDING.
CLARIFY THAT ANY REVENUE THAT IS
MADE DURING THE PILOTS.
WILL BE RE DIRECTED TO EPIC.
AND PUSHES BACK THE DATE THAT
REGULATORS WOULD CONSIDER GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN IN THE
HIGHER P..
UNDER SUBSECTION A AT THE THE
LAST LINE I THINK YOUR STAFF A
GIVEN US SOME BUT JUST TO STRIKE
OUT THAT WE WERE IN AGREEMENT
WITH THIS WAS THE LAST LINE THAT
I THINK IT READS --
AND USES ELECTRICITY FROM ZERO
CARBON [inaudible]
ELECTRICITY RESOURCES
[inaudible]
AND IT -- IN
ITS PRODUCTION.
AND WE STRUCK THAT --
BASED ON YOUR STAFF'S REQUEST
OKAY -- LET
ME JUST QUICKLY [inaudible]
IN MY YES.
THAT IS THE MEMORY PLAN TO TAKE.
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME DAY I APPRECIATE
THAT --
ANYWAY SO I DECLARE FOR THOSE
MOMENTS AND JUST BASICALLY FOR
ANYONE WHO IS --
IT THIS DOES ALLOW US TO UTILIZE
OUR RENEWABLE GENERATED
ELECTRICITY TO THROUGH AN
ELECTROLYTIC PROCESS BREAK --
WATER INTO HYDROGEN AND OXYGEN
WHICH FREES THE HYDROGEN TO THEN
BE USED AS A FUEL FOR FOR
STORAGE FOR GREAT PURPOSES.
AND IT ALLOWS US TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT IT WITHOUT ISP RIGHT VOTE
AND I HAVE MY WHICH IS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PLEASE [inaudible]
HER PRESENTATION.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF THE
BRIEF HERE.
AT SAID A PLEASURE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JEFF REED I'M THE
CHIEF SCIENTIST FOR RENEWABLE
FUELS ENERGY STORAGE AT UC
IRVINE.
I'M ALSO CURRENTLY SERVING AS
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL.
SO BOTH ORGANIZATIONS LIKE TO
VOICE THEIR STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
SENATOR SKINNER'S BILL AND
EMPHASIZES THE SINNERS HABIT.
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN CAN PLAY A
KEY ROLE.
IN SUPPORTING THE DECOLONIZATION
OF BOTH ELECTRICITY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
STARTED ON DEPLOYING THE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE NEAR TERM.
BEFORE THE NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF
SOLUTION BECOMES MORE MORE
PRESSING.
I IN THE MID PART OF THE
TWENTIES BECAUSE AS WE HEARD.
FROM SENT EARLIER I SPEAKERS
ABOUT THE DUCK CURVE WITH WHICH
YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR.
THE SOLUTION TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING THAT
LAST YEAR.
WE CURTAIL JUST ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED GIGAWATT HOURS OF
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY.
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE CPC'S --
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
TOOL PREDICTS THAT TO GO UP
[inaudible] TO THREE THOUSAND I
THAT'S ABOUT THE EQUIVALENT OF
SIMPLY SPELLING THE ENERGY OF A
ONE GIGA WATT.
SOLAR PLANT --
THE SYSTEMS ARE BEING DEPLOYED
IN EUROPE.
AND WE NEED EXPERIENCE OPERATING
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA. TO BRING
THESE RESOURCES IN ALONGSIDE
OTHERS SERVING SIMILAR PURPOSE
IN THIS CONSERVING UNIQUE
PURPOSE.
IN LONG DURATION INCLUDING
UNSEASONAL STORAGE.
SO STOP THERE AND ASK FOR A
COMMITTEES AYE VOTES.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LORRAINE PASSED SCAT
WITH A TRUE NORTH AND AQUA
HAIDAR EX.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE HAD A LONG
HEARING TODAY.
SO AYE WELL AND EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT AND APPRECIATION.
CENTER SKINNER FOR TAKING
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'M HERE TO
ANSWER THEM BUT WE'LL JUST KEEP
IT SHORT TODAY.
BUT THANK YOU FOR THAT SEWER OF
WILL WELCOME OF THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THEIR VOICES SUPPORT
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE --
STEVE WELCOME AT THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
ALSO OWNS.
HI ALEX MORRIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
WALKER RIGHT WITH ENGINE NORTH
AMERICA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GREEN NOISE FOR THE LOW CARBON
FEELS COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
REPORTER THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
OUR MAIN CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
HAVE RELATE TO THE PROVISION ON
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT MEN MEANT
TODAY AND THAT THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTED THEM SUGGESTING THE
COMEDIAN ANALYSIS WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE A QUITE GOES FAR ENOUGH TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS.
AND WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT --
FURTHER AMENDMENTS BE ADDED
HIGHER P. DATE IS MOVED OUT
ANOTHER TWO YEARS AND PROVISION
IS MADE FOR THE DATA TO MADE
PUBLIC OF THE RESULTS OF THE
PILOT PROGRAMS.
OUR MEMBERS NEED DATA ABOUT THIS
TECHNOLOGY IF THEY'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER IN THEIR IRE P. WITHOUT
THAT DATA THEY HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING HOW TO CONSIDER THEIR
IRE P..
FURTHERMORE WE THINK SOME
LANGUAGE WOULD BE NEEDED AND TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN IT'S CONSIDERED
AN IRP THAT AND COST FEASIBILITY
IS TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS THAT LIKE
TO RUIN THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WILL TURN BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
DOCTOR QUIRK --
I'M I'M IN THERE.
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS.
ALRIGHT NOW I'VE HYDROGEN
VEHICLE [inaudible]
WITHOUT [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
PROGRAM WE WILL NEVER HAVE
HYDROGEN VEHICLES IN THIS STATE.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW HYDROGEN COSTS.
EQUIVALENT OF EIGHT DOLLARS A
GALLON [inaudible]
OF GAS IT.
WHEN YOU USING THE HYDROGEN?
YOU'RE EITHER IT'S GONNA COST
YOU WHAT IT WOULD HAVE GAS WAS
EIGHT DOLLARS A GALLON TO BE
MORE PRECISE.
AND HOW CAN WE BRING THAT THAT
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
RIGHT NOW TWO THIRDS OF THE
ELECT OF THE HYDROGEN COUNTRY
NATURAL GAS.
IF THIS IS GONNA WORK IN THE
LONG RUN IT HAS TO COME FROM
ELECTROLYSIS WHICH IS WHAT YOUR
BILL IS PILOTING.
AND FURTHERMORE WE JUST DON'T
KNOW UNTIL WE SCALE OP.
HOW WELL THIS WILL WORK NOW I
CAN TALK I HAVE TALKED WITH
TECHNOLOGISTS?
TO FAST AND KNOW ALL ABOUT THIS
AND THEY SAY --
WE'VE REALLY GOTTEN THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE POINT WHERE WE
CAN USE VERY SMALL AMOUNTS OF
PLATINUM AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THAT EXPENSIVE AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY THAT MUCH ABOUT
THE END NODES IN THE CAFETERIA
AND TO BE REPLACED IN THE
CHANNEL TO SCALE UP.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS IT GIVES
US.
THE FIRST PART OF THE SCALE.
IT'S NOT ALL THE WAY SCALE UP
BUT IT'S THE NEXT STEP.
AND WITHOUT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
WE WON'T SCALE UP WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN WELL ELECTRIC CARS ARE
GOING TO BE GOOD FOR PEOPLE
COMMUTE SMALLER DISTANCES --
PEOPLE WHO HAVE READILY OF IT
READY AVAILABILITY OF CHARGING
BUT THAT'S JUST NOT EVERYBODY.
AND SOME PEOPLE WILL NEVER
ADOPTED AND SO.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE
ELECTROLYSIS OF HYDROGEN AND
HYDROGEN VEHICLES IN MY OPINION.
AS A SECOND OPTION FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE RANGE ANXIETY FOR
PEOPLE WITH HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
BOB THAT'S ONE USE THE OTHER
THAT I HEARD --
TALKED ABOUT BY SUPPORTERS WAS
STORAGE --
YES BATTERIES YOU'RE GOOD IN
SOME WAYS BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SEASONAL STORAGE.
WHICH AT SOME POINT IF WE HAVE
ENOUGH SOLAR IT'S A DIRECTION WE
GO IN.
THEN HYDROGEN IS A GOOD WAY TO
GO.
SO FOR THOSE MANY REASONS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
I IS THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
PRESERVE SECOND.
HOW SENATOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ALWAYS FORWARD THINKING IN THESE
ISSUES AND WE?
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL DO PASS.
TO A NATURAL RESOURCES WITH THE
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD BEEN
ACCEPTED WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU PREACH HATE TO WORK
WITH COMMITTEE AND* FOR NOT
BOTH -- SO
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN A
NATURAL RESOURCE.
BUT IS A DO PASS [inaudible]
LOCAL.
HOLDEN HIGH HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
RICHIE AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TING.
HOW THE BILL'S UNCLE?
SEE -- SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR SOONER
LEYVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR WHAT
SUPPORT AND ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BATTERY ELECTRIC
TRANSIT BUSES BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO INITIATE A RATE
MAKING PROCEEDING THAT ADDRESSES
THE HIGH COST OF ELECTRICITY AS
A FUEL.
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OR REPLACING
CONVENTIONAL FUEL TRANSIT BUSES
WITH BATTERY ELECTRIC TRANSIT
BUSES.
HE TRANSIT AS TRANSIT AGENCIES
MOVED TO AND SCALE UP THEIR
DEPLOYMENT A BATTERY ELECTRIC
BUSES.
MANY HAVE FOUND THAT THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY FAR EXCEEDS
CONVENTIONAL FUEL.
IN FACT SOME TRANSIT AGENCIES
HAVE FOUND THAT THE COST OF FUEL
PER MILE FOR ELECTRIC BUSES CAN
BE 40% TO TWO TIMES HIGHER THE
NATURAL GAS AND DIESEL FUEL.
THIS HIGH COST REMAINS TRUE EVEN
WITH STATE INCENTIVES SUCH AS
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD.
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WITH FOR WHICH
REPRESENTS MORE THAN EIGHTY
TRANSIT AGENCIES IN THE STATE
HAS IDENTIFIED THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY IS ONE OF THE TOP
THREE BARRIERS. TO TRANSIT
ELECTRIFICATION THE HIGH COST OF
ELECTRICITY AS A FUEL IS
PREVENTING AND SLOWING THE
ADOPTION OF CLEANER ENERGY
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS VITAL TO ME
THE STATE'S S. B. THIRTY TWO
GOALS.
REDUCING PETROLEUM USED BY 50%
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND IMPROVING
OUR STATE'S AIR QUALITY.
AS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
RECENTLY IS CURRENTLY ADVANCING
REGULATIONS REQUIRE ALL TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO PURCHASE ZERO
EMISSION BUSES THE NEED TO FIND
A SOLUTION HAS BECOME MORE
URGENT.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR IS
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S GOALS
OF TRANSITIONING TO CLEANER
ENERGY AND REDUCING TOXIC
POLLUTANTS IN THE AIR.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
ENSURE THE BILL DOES NOT DELAY
OTHER.
ONGOING EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
TRANSIT ELECTRIFICATION AND I
HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT HERE WITH
ME TODAY [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
COME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
HIMSELF CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION.
THE ASSOCIATION IS A SPONSOR OF
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR LEYVA DID A GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING THE INTENT BEHIND S.
B. FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR SO I
WON'T GO INTO. TOO MUCH DETAIL
ALL OSES THAT THE BILL BEFORE
YOU CAME NEARLY JUMP STARTS A
CONVERSATION THE CPUC AROUND
RIGHT DESIGNED TO SUPPORT. ZERO
MISSION BUS DEPLOYMENT WE
ANTICIPATE THE CPUC WOULD STILL
ADHERE TO MANY OF THEIR LONG
STANDING UP PRINCIPLES A
GOVERNING REDESIGN IN DECIDING
WHETHER TO APPROVE.
A NEW RATES WERE TRANSIT
AGENCIES WITH PHYLLIS
CONVERSATIONS IMPORTANT FOR
PREVENTING ELECTRICITY RATES
FROM SLOWING THE ADOPTION ZERO
EMISSION BUSES.
AND WE ASK YOUR AYE THAT THANK
YOU.
I'M MORE COMMANDING --
I'M FROM LA METRO --
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE IN --
SO -- AND
SENIOR DIRECTOR VEHICLE
ENGINEERING AND ACQUISITION
FRAWLEY METRO AND WE ARE.
COMMITTED TO CONVERTING OUR
FLEET ZERO EMISSION BUSES BY --
TWENTY THIRTY RIGHT AND THAT'S A
FLEET OF OVER TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED BOSSES AND ITS SERVERS
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
PASSENGERS JUST LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE ORDERS OF A HUNDRED FIVE
ELECTRIC BUSES ORDER.
ON THAT WE'RE JOINED ELECTRIFY
ARE SO OVER AN ORANGE LINES.
WE KNOW AS AS BOTH --
BOTH PEOPLE HAVE POINTED OUT THE
SENATOR AND OUT MIKE THEM UNTIL
HAVE POINTED OUT WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE CRUCIAL TO
MAKING SURE WE MAINTAIN OUR
OPERATING COSTS.
AS MENTIONED THERE APPEAR
AGENCIES THAT I'VE ALREADY SEEN
THAT ELECTRIC A BOSS COULD BE
SIXTY EIGHT TO A 100% MORE THAN
THE INCUMBENT TECHNOLOGY THE CNG
OR DIESEL --
JUST TO SAY FROM LA METROS POINT
OF VIEW WE SPENT TWENTY THREE
MILLION AND CNG JUST LAST YEAR.
THAT MEANS WE WOULD SPEND FORTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ELECTRICITY COSTS IF WE DO NOT
HAVE A GUARANTEED TRANSIT
FRIENDLY RIGHT --
AYE I PREVIOUSLY JUST CAME FROM
CHICAGO TRANSIT WE WERE
GRAPPLING WITH THE SAME ISSUE
WITH OUR ELECTRIC BUSES --
WE ALSO DID HAVE SOME TRANSIT
FRIENDLY RIGHT AS WELL FOR OUR
WELL OUR RAILROADS THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT SO THIS IS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A COST
EFFECTIVE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF ELECTRIC BUSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY
HUNTER ARMY OF THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AROUND
SOCIAL UNITS WERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY SANTA MONICA'S BIG BLUE
BUS.
AS WELL AS A SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
BOTH IN SUPPORT THANKS.
A MAN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HI ENGER PEPSIN WITH FOOTHILLS
TRANSIT STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VINCE WHERE MODULE WITH WIDENING
GROUP ON THAT BE WIDELY MOTORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CHARLES WATSON ON BEHALF
PROTECTOR IN SUPPORT.
THE WELCOME AFTER SENATOR
TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENT AC
TRANSIT'S THE NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY --
AND CAL FOR SUCH AS RECORDED
TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SILVIUS
ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE AT ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY AND SUPPORT.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HATE THIS NOT OPPOSITION AND
REBEKAH LEE ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON --
WE ARE PLANNING TO ROLL OUT A
TRANSIT FRIENDLY REYES AND WE
HAVE OFFERED PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO THE AUTHOR AND VERY HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT --
WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK SURE TO MAKING SURE THAT --
NOTHING IN THIS BILL WOULD
INADVERTENTLY DELAY OUR EXISTING
EFFORT TO SUPPORT A TRANSIT
ELECTRIFICATION AS PART OF A
WIDESPREAD MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY
ELECTRIFICATION STRATEGY SO.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD WERE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER ARE ARE CONCERNED AND I
THINK WE WERE WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO WORK SOMETHING OUT WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IS WE DON'T WANT
ONE SET OF RATEPAYERS TO BE
SUBSIDIZING ANOTHER SET.
I THINK WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
HOPEFULLY WE CAN ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS VALUE TRAIL
OF LAJOS PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY --
JUST SAD MIMIC THE CONCERNS ARE
EXPRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUES FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC.
COMPANY WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR --
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING AND THAT WE
HAVE CONCERNS AND IN HER
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
AT JULIE NINE ASK ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION THANK
YOU FOR OFFERING TO WORK WITH US
IN OUR CONCERNS BEFORE TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU OF OR THE ANY
QUESTIONS.
OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR THE SENATE
MOVE THE BELL.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
THEY DO PASSED.
TO COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE.
SENATOR WOULD YOU OUT LIKE TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
OKAY.
WITH THAT --
CALL THE ROLL.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I BURKE [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES SHE RECEIVED SHE AYE QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
OF THE BILLS ON CALL --
BUT WE APPRECIATE PRESENTATION
WILL.
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AS MEMBERS
COMMAND AND WILL ADD ON THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
TOM IF I COULD I'D LIKE TO CALL
A TEN MINUTE RECESS [inaudible]
OR
YOU [inaudible]
COULD [inaudible]
BUT YEAH [inaudible]
WELL.
YEAH I DON'T THINK [inaudible]
BUT NO [inaudible]
WHITE HOUSE
[inaudible]
MY
SO WE'RE BACK FOR RECESS AND
SENATOR OF HUESO WE APOLOGIZE
FOR THE SLIGHT DELAY BUT
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY. TO PRESENT ON FOURTEEN
FORTY AND SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME REALLY
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR HELP WITH THIS
BILL.
AND I'D LIKE TO ALSO THANK YOUR
STAFF -- TO
WERE FOR YOUR STAFF WORKING WITH
US ON THIS --
THANK YOU --
YOU KNOW THIS IS--
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
PUT CALIFORNIA.
ON A NEW PATH WITH REGARDS.
TO RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
EVERY DAY WERE SEEN --
THE AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
WERE SEEN.
ANIMALS ACTUALLY MIGRATING
NORTHWARD WERE SEEN.
BOB WILDFIRES --
RAVAGING PARTS OF OUR STATE
MOVING.
EVERY YEAR CLINTON FURTHER NORTH
AND THEN A ELIMINATING OUR
FORESTS WERE SEEN --
THE AFFECTS [inaudible]
OF OF GHGS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
CAUSING CLIMATE CHANGE CAUSING
GLOBAL WARMING CAUSING.
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER
[inaudible]
AT TAKING ON POLICIES THAT IT
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY THAT --
THERE'LL LEADING THE WORLD IN
REDUCE SEEN [inaudible]
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THIS BILL IS A BILL THAT --
BRINGS CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
MUCH CLOSER TO CONTINUE AND
ACHIEVE THAT --
THIS LEGISLATURE STARTED ITS
WORK.
ON THE CARBONIZATION OF THE
ELECTRIC SECTOR. TO THE ADOPTION
OF STATUTORY.
OUR PROCUREMENT MANDATES FOR
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY WE'VE GONE
THROUGH.
THIS A RENEWABLE ENERGY
REVOLUTION IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
NOT ONLY CREATE JOBS BUT ALSO
HAS HOT HELPED US.
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND HELP A
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND TODAY WE CAN SAY THAT WERE A
HEAD OF SCHEDULE. TO GET 50%
RENEWABLE ACT LICKED TRICITY
[inaudible]
A BY TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY WE'RE
MAKING HUGE CHANGES.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER PART OF OUR
OF OUR ECONOMY THAT WE NEED TO
CUT DE CARBONIZED.
AN AREA WHERE WE USE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF ENERGY AND THAT'S
NATURAL GAS CALIFORNIA STILL
EXPORTS.
IMPORTS 80% OF OUR NATURAL GAS
EVERY TIME WE USE NATURAL GAS
AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S MONEY FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOING TO SOME.
FOREIGN ENTITIES SOME OTHER PART
OF THE COUNTRY OTHER PART OF THE
STATE.
AND THAT'S LESS MONEY.
THAT WERE RECIRCULATING INTO OUR
OWN ECONOMY. ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS I DID WHEN I GOT THE
SENATE WAS I STARTED THE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
ON OUR ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS
THAT HELPS US GET [inaudible]
TO CLOSER TO BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
TODAY WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
INDUSTRY OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
INVESTING.
IN CREATING A RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS THESE ARE COMPANIES THERE
ARE.
ARE CAPTURING METHANE TURNING
INTO POWER POWERING --
ALTOS THEIR POWER POWER IN
INDUSTRY.
AND AND WE NEED.
TO TAP INTO THAT KNOWLEDGE TAP
INTO THAT INDUSTRY TO HELP CLEAN
CALIFORNIA'S AARON HELP FUEL.
OUR FUTURE.
WE'VE DONE AWESOME WORK IN THIS
BILL A RECENTLY --
RECENTLY ARE WE WE PASSED S. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT WHICH
WAS OFFERED ARE AUTHORED BY
SENATOR RICARDO LARA WHICH WILL
DIVORCE DIVERT 75%.
OF ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS
AND REDUCE METHANE EMISSIONS BY
40% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS IS OUR A A
VERY AMBITIOUS BILL.
BUT A BILL THAT IS MUCH NEEDED
AND A BILL THAT NEEDS.
ARE A PATHWAY TO BE IMPLEMENTED
MY BILL WOULD WOULD BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN IMPLEMENTING.
THIS PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A MARKET. FOR FOR THAT
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IN A WAY.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO PROCURE
THIS IN STATE.
SO -- I JUST
WANTED -- TO
S. EXPRESS THAT UP I KNOW THERE
ARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE THE PRICE YOU PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL.
AND THEY ARE --
EXTREMELY CONFUSING I UNDERSTAND
AND WE'VE MADE LOTS OF CHANGES
TO THAT BUT IT'S BEEN A KIND OF
A PROCESS BY WHICH WE'VE.
WE'VE ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS IN
THIS INDUSTRY TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION OF WORKS TO MAKE SENSE.
THAT IS IMPLEMENTABLE THAT CAN
ACTUALLY BE ACCOMPLISHED.
AND IT'S BEEN A HARD ROAD
GETTING HERE AND WE'RE WILLING
TO WORK WITH HIM AS CHAIR YOU
HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THEM TODAY. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF WORKING OUT THE
DETAILS OF THOSE AND I I KNOW
THAT.
WE WE WILL NEED SOME LEVEL OF OF
COST CONTAINMENT AND COST CAPS
AND ARE YOU UNDERSTOOD USE SPORT
THAT.
I SUPPORT THAT I WON'T I WON'T
WORK ON THIS BILL WITHOUT THAT
WE NEED TO CONTROL THE COSTS
THAT ARE PASSED.
PASSED ON RATEPAYERS.
A THAT'S GONNA BE A VERY
ESSENTIAL PART OF THIS BILL --
SO I'M I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT.
BUT YOU KNOW I HAVE --
PLENTY OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE A LOT
MORE EXPERTISE AND ON THIS THAN
I DO THAT ARE WILLING TO KIND OF
SHARE.
SOME OF THEIR SOME OF THEIR
EXPERTISE WITH THIS COMMITTEE SO
THAT YOU --
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE PUTTING
ON TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND AND AND MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WOULD LIKE --
TO TYPE I APPRECIATE FIRST OF
ALL I APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED --
VISIONARY THINKING AROUND HOW TO
EXPAND OUR RENEWABLES IN THE
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WE MIGHT --
START START TO EXPLORE AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THE
AMENDMENT --
FOR CLARITY THAT WERE.
ARE PROPOSING WHICH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
A IS STRIKING ON PAGE --
EIGHT LINES.
EIGHTEEN TO FORTY AND ALL OF
PAGE.
NINE NOW THE RESULTS THE RESULT
OF THAT WOULD BE.
THE BILL WOULD BE DIRECT WOULD
DIRECT.
AKAR.
DEVELOPER PROCUREMENT MANDATE
PROGRAM.
WITHOUT THE USE OF RACE CLEAR
THOUGHTS.
BUT TO YOUR POINT IN TERMS OF
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON THE
COST CONTAINMENT WEEK.
THAT'S THAT'S DEFINITELY GOING
TO HAPPEN DA OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH.
DID YOU WANNA HEAR SOME WEST
WITNESS TESTIMONY.
PLEASE OF WE WILL WILL CO HEAD
INJURY AT THE REQUIREMENT THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS FOR THE PROUD SPONSORS THE
SAW AND LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR --
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US ON
APPROPRIATE COST CONTAINMENT
MEASURES AND WE THINK THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
I ACTUALLY HAD A FEW OF MY
MEMBERS FLY IN FROM OUT HOUND SO
I'LL BE YIELDING MY TIME SO THAT
ON THEY CAN.
ADDRESS YOU THINK YOU.
FLYING IN FROM ONTARIO IS NOT
THAT BIG A FLIGHT BUT YEAH MINDS
ROB STRANGE WORK FOR FOUR STAR
ENERGY AND TWO STAR ENERGY --
WHERE A ON?
WELL.
WE I'M NATIONWIDE FIRM THAT DOES.
SUPPORTS A LOW CARBON ASSETS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE HAVE
THIRTY THREE LEVEL GAS ENERGY
PLANTS CROSS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A THREE YEAR
COGENERATION PLANTS AND FIVE
BIOMASS FACILITIES.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THAT.
GET A WERE FLARE MORE GAS IN THE
STATE TWICE AS MUCH MORE GAS IN
THE STATE THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN AND WE NEED TO OUR FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE GONNA DO WITH ALL
NOTHING LARS BILL WAS GREAT
MARGRET.
KEEP THE ORGANICS FROM GOING IN
THE LANDFILL.
BUT THE AVERAGE GAS CURVE IN A
LANDFILL THIS IS OUR BUSINESS
[inaudible] TWENTY YEARS.
MY GUESS IS STILL THERE --
EFFECT WE DON'T PUT A MORE IN
DOES MAKE ANYMORE.
BUT THE ORGANICS PROCESS OF
DECOMPOSING IN MAKING THAT
METHANE TAKES TWENTY YEARS AS WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
WITH THIS GAS IN THE MEANTIME --
ALSO FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WITH WITH AG IN THEIR DISTRICTS --
THE FARMERS ARE GOING TO BENEFIT
FOR THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
HAVE --
ORGANICS IN THEIR PART OF THEIR
WASTE STREAM AND THAT ORGANICS A
OUR OUR GOING TO BE --
SHORT LIVE CLIMATE PRETTY
POLLUTANTS AND WE'RE CAPTURING
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE USING.
TO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT RENEWABLE
BIOGAS THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
I THINK VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS OF LIKE.
TO BUT ATTENTION AND WOULD JUST
RIGHT AND IF YOU KEEP IT IN A
ONE TO TWO MINUTES BRIEFLY I
THANK YOU A CHECK TIM CARMICHAEL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY.
WE'VE BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
THIS BILL ON ITS DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORTING ALL ALONG --
I WANT TO SPEAK JUST TO A COUPLE
OF QUICK POINTS --
THIRD PERSON BEEN SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THIS BILL BEING.
PREMATURE WE DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS CORRECT OF THIS SPACE
THIS ENERGY SPACE IS MOVING
RAPIDLY THERE DOZENS OF PROJECTS
IN DEVELOPMENT WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD HELP
US FACILITATE THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION AND USE OF THOSE
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD --
THAT'S WHY ONE OF THE REASONS
WE'VE BEEN SO KEEN.
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL ON HEARD
THE DISCUSSION BETWEEN.
YOU AND SENATOR OF THE AUTHOR
ABOUT OTHER PROVISIONS THAT.
YEAR YOU'D LIKE TO SEE REMOVED
WERE BUT THAT BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THE COST CONTROLS AND THE RATE
FACING PROVISIONS ARE. TO THE
MOST CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF THIS
BILL FOR SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED THEIR
INCLUSION --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION OVER THE NEXT FEW
DAYS WE HOPE TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THOSE --
OTHERWISE WE'RE LOOKING AT
SITUATION WHERE THERE'D BE A
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT --
A MECHANISM TO REALLY PAY FOR IT
AND THAT'S A BIG CONCERN. FOR US
BUT THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
THE WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
UP MIND SHOPPERS OLEUM ASSET
MANAGER FOR OUR ENERGY ON A
MISSION AND A WOMAN THE LARGEST
PRODUCERS OF OUR ENERGY IN THE
COUNTRY AND WERE A MAJOR PLAYER
IN THE TRANSPORTATION FUELS
MARKET.
WERE ALSO MAJOR SUPPLIER --
IN SUPPORT OF THE OUR PS IN
CALIFORNIA HERE SO WE WE SUPPLY
OF NUMEROUS MUNICIPALITIES IN
CALIFORNIA --
WE PROCESSED OVER FIFTY ABBY CF
OF OUR ENGINES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT'S EQUIVALENT OF
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DE THREE
RENTS --
THAT'S LIKE TAKING A FORMALLY
CARS OFF THE ROAD WE TOOK
SEVENTEEN MILLION TONS OF CO TWO
OUT OF THE BY THE ATMOSPHERE
LAST YEAR --
WE WE DISAGREE WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ON THE ANALYSIS FROM
THE COMEDIAN AL SAYS THAT
PIPELINE INJECTED COST IS IS NOT
IT COST COMPETITIVE.
OF THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
BIFURCATION OF THE COMMODITY AND
MP AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ATTRIBUTES MAKING THE NATURAL
GAS ESSENTIALLY THE SAME LAST --
BUT SO MARKETS ARE FAR MORE
MATURE THAN THE ENERGY MARKETS
AND SO IT'S HARD TO PREDICT WHAT
THAT FUTURE MIGHT LOOK LIKE --
BUT POSTLE PRICES --
PICKED IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE OVER
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AND WE'RE OVER.
TWELVE AS RECENTLY AS TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THIS IS SMART
POLICY BECAUSE IT ALLOWS --
CALIFORNIA DIVERSIFY ITS NATURAL
GAS SUPPLY --
ARE IT WILL HAVE ON NINE
PROJECTS IN PRODUCTION AT THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ANOTHER SEVEN OR IN DEVELOPMENT
AND TO WHICH ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THIS BILL WILL HELP GET THOSE
PROJECTS MOVING.
UP PASSING SB FOURTEEN FORTY
PROVIDES.
CRITICAL CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET
AND ACCESS TO CAPITAL --
PASSING SB FORTY FORTY WOULD
CREATE A HUNDRED FIFTY NEW RG
PROJECTS WITH A CAPITAL
EXPENDITURE OF UP TO TEN POINT
FIVE BILLION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WILL TAKE.
EXCUSE ME OTHERS WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK OR JUST GIVE YOUR YOUR
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL SO JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION THANK YOU --
JULIE MANAUS GIVE ALL THE HAVE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE HAS THE SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON AND FUTURE TWEAKS TO
THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST GAGA GROUND
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SANITATION AGENCIES HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT.
MY DILLON REPRESENTING COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
I A RYAN KENNY CLEAN ENERGY WE
ARE THE NATION'S LARGEST
PROVIDER OF BY NOTHING
TRANSPORTATION FUEL WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR CAN YOU CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US ON MINUTES.
WE ARE MOVING OPPOSITION AND ARE
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH
POND AND THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL HUNDRED COMPANIES I
REPRESENT IN ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY CITIES AND THOSE
COMPANIES.
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'D JUST GIVE YOU ONE PIECE
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
WE HAVE TWENTY MILLION TONS OF
ORGANICS TO GET OUT OF THE
LANDFILL BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY MILLION TONS.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AVENUES SO
WE NEED THIS TO BE ONE OF THE
MANY AVENUES TO DO THAT JOB.
THANK YOU SIR.
GREEN NOISE ON BIAFRA FULCRUM
BIOENERGY FULCRUM IS DEVELOPING
A STATE OF THE ART FACILITY
TAKING A SIMPLE SOLID WASTE AND
GASIFIER IT --
AND THAT IS A RESOURCE THAT
CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY NEEDS ON
THE DIVERSION --
AND THE YES SITES OR TO SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION THEY'D LIKE
TO BE BUILDING FACILITIES HERE.
MICHAEL BOCA DOOR ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO ON A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WE'VE BEEN
SEEKING THREE AMENDMENTS. ONE OF
WHICH DEALS WITH COST
CONTAINMENT ON THE
INTERCONNECTION SIDE TO REDUCE
IT FROM A 100% THAT'S CURRENTLY
IN THE BILL 250% WHICH WOULD PUT
SOME ADDITIONAL CONTROLS ON
COSTS WHICH WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
WE NEED TO CLEAN UP THE
DEFINITION OF FOOD PROCESSING
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN THE BILL.
AND WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT THE
HOW CREDITS THAT ARE GENERATED
REMAIN WITH THE PRODUCER UNLESS
THE PRODUCER AGREES TO INCLUDE
THAT AS PART OF THE THE
AGREEMENT WITH THE PROCUREMENT
SO.
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS WE CAN BE
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JULIA ELEVEN BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
THANK THE AUTHOR VERY MUCH THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL THE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS VERY VERY MUCH.
AND WE ARE ALSO SUPPORT IF
AMENDED BUT HOPING TO MOVE TO
FULL SUPPORT IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF DAYS WITH AMENDMENTS.
OBSERVADOR MENTION THE NEED TO
CLARIFY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CREDITS WE ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
VEHICLE FUELS MARKET CONTINUE TO
BE A COMPETITIVE MARKET.
AND WITH THOSE CHANGES WE WILL
MOVE TO STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE OF THAT COMMITTEE LARA
NOLAND HAGIA COME BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA JERRY
SEEN CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND WESTERN ON PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT IF
AMENDED --
WITH THE AMENDMENTS EXPRESSED BY
AG ENERGY CONSUMERS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTER NOON
VALERIE TRAIL OF LAJOS PGM
AND ON THE WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL THINKING IF
YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL I'M AND
THE AUTHOR --
REGRETTABLY.
IF THE COST CONTAINMENT
PROVISIONS ARE REMOVED WITHOUT
STRONG.
UMBER BUST OFF RAMP PGD WOULD
HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL --
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION THAT YOU'RE OFFERING
TO HAVE A A CONVERSATION WITH
ALL THE STATE THAT HAVE SAT DOWN
TOGETHER FOR MANY MANY MONTHS.
ON TO WORK OUT --
SOME DETAILS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK.
WE WILL NOW A I'M SORRY YOU JUST
A ME TOO YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
KWGN WITH THE CALIFORNIA CITY
COUNCIL LABORERS ALSO IN SUPPORT
FOR THE TWENTY SIX THOUSAND JOBS
WOULD CREATE THANK YOU.
YOU.
ARE THERE --
HAS ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC TO
SEE WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AND AND WE'LL JUST TAKE A FEW
JUST AS WITNESSES SO WHOEVER.
WAS PREPARED TO COME IN AS A
WITNESS --
LET'S MAKE SOME ROOM FOR THEM
.
PATCHWORK THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AYE WE HAVE AN OPPOSED POSITION
ON THE BILL THAT'S CURRENTLY AND
IN PRNT AT WITH REGARDS TO
DRIVE RATE PAIR IMPACTS WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S HARD WORK
ON THIS IN THE NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS THEY'VE HAD
WE BEEN INVOLVED IN THOSE.
AND AND AND ALSO APPRECIATE
BETWEEN HOUSES FOCUS ON IMPACTS
TO RATEPAYERS WE SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS --
IF I'M UNDERSTANDING AMENDMENTS
CORRECTLY THAT THE THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL THAT ALLOWS US COST
BE PASSED ON TO REPAIRS IS BEING
REMOVED.
AFRAM THE BILL WE THINK THAT'S
MOVING THE BILL IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
IF I'M UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY I
HEARD ONE OF THE SUPPORTERS UP
HERE SAYING THAT THE BILL
PROVIDES ACCESS TO CAPITAL BACK
CAPITAL IS OR MEMBERS THE
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES WHO.
BY NATURAL GAS AND PAY THE COSTS
UNDER THIS MANDATE AND AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS ON A REPAIR
IMPACTS IN THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
FORTY BEING INVOLVED IN FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS AS THE AUTHOR IN
THIS COMMITTEE ENGAGE IN --
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT THE
FUTURE THIS BILL AND AND RATE
RECOVERY LANGUAGE BUT WE THINK
THAT THE FOCUS ON REPAIRS NEEDS
TO BE A FRIENDS.
IN THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK A PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
AUTHOR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
AND ALL THE OTHER STATE.
A STAKEHOLDERS --
ON THIS PROCESS BEFORE WE HAVE
VISITED WITH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
AND OTHERS --
IN OUR OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE DID SIT DOWN WITH
THE AUTHORS.
STAFF AND LET THEM KNOW THAT --
WITH THE BILL SET BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAD TO A AYE
AYE INDICATE WHERE WE ARE.
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT FROM A
REPUBLIC STAND FOR PLOT POINT WE
ARE -- WE
WERE AN EARLY SUPPORTER OF SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE I BELIEVE
WE WERE THE FIRST SOLID WASTE
COMPANY.
TO TAKE THAT POSITION AND SO
WERE VERY --
ACT --
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA OF
ADDRESSING --
METHANE AND REDUCING THE AND
THAT S. FOURTEEN FORTY WOULD
CREATE A BIAS AGAINST A BIO
METHANE FROM LANDFILL GAS
PROJECTS.
I THE BILL PRIORITIZES HIGH
COSTS IN GAS I PRODUCED BY
COMMERCIAL WE BELIEVE ARE
COMMERCIALLY UNPROVEN.
STAFF THERMAL GASIFICATION AT
GASIFICATION AND WE ARE
CONCERNED.
THAT THIS BILL INCLUDES SYNGAS
PRODUCED BY GASIFICATION.
YEAH IN THE EXISTING STE --
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF BIOGAS I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
CONSTITUENCIES OF BIOGAS.
WHY ARE 5275% METHANE --
SYNGAS HAS NO METHANE AT ALL AND
SO I WOULD WANT TO POINT OUT TO
THE COMMITTEE THAT.
I WE SEEM TO BE TRYING TO BUY CO
MINGLING THESE I THINK WE ARE
DOING -- BIO
METHANE COLLECTION AND
PROCESSING AYE IN USE AT A
DISSERVICE AND SO WE WOULD URGE
AYE WE PRESENTED SOME AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD CLARIFY THOSE
DEFINITIONS --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WITH THE OTHER BODIES
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY TO GET THIS
BILL RIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS INGRID
ROSTRUM I'M WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUP
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF KERN
COUNTY RESIDENTS.
ON THIS BILL CREATES A PERVERSE
INCENTIVE TO SPUR MORE METHANE.
TO CONSOLIDATE AND INCREASE
HEARD AND SUBSIDIZE THE LARGEST
AND MOST POLLUTING CARRIES ON
MANY OF WHICH OCCUR IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY --
RATHER --
THEN LOOK AT WAYS OF DEALING
WITH EXISTING METHANE AYE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZE AND PRACTICES THAT
REDUCE METHANE GENERATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT COULD INCLUDE.
MOVEMENT TOWARD DRY MANURE
MANAGEMENT RATHER THAN THE WET
MANURE MANAGEMENT THAT WE
CURRENTLY SEEING CALIFORNIA.
I DAIRIES HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
LOCALIZED IMPACTS ON RESIDENTS
IN THE CENTER VALLEY INCLUDING
KERN AND TULARE.
ON AND THESE RESIDENTS OR EIGHTY
SUFFER FROM A COMMUNITY
CUMULATIVE AND ENVIRONMENTAL --
POLLUTION BIRD.
ON BY INCENTIVIZING LARGER
DAIRIES AND LARGER HEARD SIZES
ON INCREASING NOTHING PRODUCTION
AND THAT'LL LEAD TO ACTING AT
INCREASED LOCALIZED IMPACTS
INCLUDING.
A WORSE AIR QUALITY --
POOR WATER QUALITY AND INCREASED
VOTER ISSUES --
FOR THESE REASONS OUT WE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT OPPOSE
POSITION.
I THINK IF.
THANK YOU OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO NAME AND WAS CHAIRMAN JOHN
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL WOULD
POSE LESS AMENDED BECAUSE WE
THINK THE BILL --
NARROWS THE DEFINITION OF
RENEWABLE GAS THAT WAS IN.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE THINK
IT SHOULD INCLUDE RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN ALONG WITH THE OTHER
PRODUCTS WE HOPE TO KEEP WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT ISSUE
THANK YOU.
PHOEBE SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE'LL LINE OUR COMMENT WAS SENT
ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT ESPECIALLY CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE IMPACTS FROM DAIRIES
ON NON NEARBY COMMUNITIES IN THE
REGION AND WE ALSO FEEL THAT
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE AND THAT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN REALLY THE
IMPACTS ON THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THE PILOT PROGRAMS SPEWS.
FAN OF US IS THAT CALIFORNIA
RAMTHA JUST SCIENCE WE ALSO AND
OUR SOULS WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND ALSO WITH CENTER
PROTEIN ARMINDO COMMENTS THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER FEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND OUR OPPOSITION IS
ALIGNED WITH THAT OF THE CENTER
FOR RACE POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT.
A MAN ON THE US EUROPE OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS GREAT COOK WAS
INTO THE CALIFORNIA POWER EIGHT
TO SEE WE HAVE BEEN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF OF THE HARD WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE TO TRY TO BRING THE
PARTIES TOGETHER.
AND FORCE THE WHEN IT WAS A DO
SO BUT WITH THE AMENDMENTS AS I
UNDERSTAND WHERE ADOPTED THIS
AFTERNOON WE WILL WITHDRAW OUR
OPPOSITION.
AND ALEXANDER ON BEHALF OF SMOG
WE WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT UNLESS AMENDED AND WE WILL --
LOOK FOR TO ANALYZING THE
AMENDMENTS WHEN THEY'RE OUT
THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
KEVIN HALL I'M UP FROM FRESNO
FOR THE DAY ENOUGH EN MASSE FOR
NINETY SECONDS OF YOUR TIME --
I'M A FORMER AGRICULTURE I
WORKED IN INDUSTRY FOR MORE THAN
THIRTEEN YEARS I'M A LIFELONG
VALLEY RESIDENTS.
AIR POLLUTION THE CLIMATE CHANGE
ARE MY TOP CONCERNS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
I THINK YOU RECOGNIZE PROBABLY
MORE THAN MOST PEOPLE HERE
IMPACTED AREAS ON ONE'S AND AIR
DISTRICT AND AIR BASIN AND THE
MOVEMENT FROM CHINO HILLS TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY OF THE MEGA
DAIRY INDUSTRY HAS HAD A
DRAMATIC IMPACT.
WITH A POPULATION OF FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A THOUSAND AREAS.
THEY REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY ONE
FOURTH OF 1% OF THE POPULATION.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FIVE
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS THAT OUR AIR
DISTRICT TO SUPPOSED
[inaudible]
TO CONTROL.
TERRY'S ALONE ACCOUNT FOR A FULL
25%.
YET THOSE.
ONE THOUSAND MAJOR SOURCES OF
POLLUTION YOUR ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO HAVE TITLE FIVE PERMITS.
SO THE NOTION THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PUT MONEY INTO THAT
INDUSTRY --
IS IS I THINK A A BACKWARDS MOVE.
AND SECONDLY I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD KEEP IN MIND IT'S A VERY
FRAGILE INDUSTRY.
A DECADE AGO THERE A THIRTEEN
HUNDRED IN THE VALLEY I'M AND
I'M SORRY I I SORRY BUT A BIT.
THE TESTIMONY PART HAS CEASED
AYE I GAVE YOU A LITTLE AT A TWO
THANK YOU I'M GONNA HAVE TO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
FOR MAYBE.
OF THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU --
SENATOR.
FOR BRINGING YOUR BILL FORWARD I
SHARE THE CONCERNS ABOUT --
IMPACT ON THE RATE PAYERS AND SO
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT --
I UNDERSTAND THE THE BILL --
AS I ASSUME IT WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION --
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK YOU --
GIVEN THAT THIS BILL WILL BE
GOING. TO MY COMMITTEE NEXT --
NATURAL RESOURCES --
A POINT THAT --
MY STAFF HAD POINT --
REYES.
AND I WANTED TO ASK YOU WHY THIS
BILL IS REQUIRING THE A A RP
RATHER THAN THE PC --
TO SET THE TERMS OF THE BY A
METHANE PROCUREMENT.
CAN I ASK A ETHNIC PORTA ANSWER
SO THERE'S TWO REASONS --
TICKLISH WITH MY REASONS
CHAIRMAN RICHARD YOU --
ONE THIS IS ACTUALLY AN
AMENDMENT WAS REQUIRED BY SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IT'S NEW
YEARS ALL VERSION OF THE BILL
DID IDENTIFY THE CPU SEE --
HOWEVER THERE IS A REPORT THAT
WAS DONE --
IN THE INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY
REPORT THAT'S DEVELOPED BY THE
CDC I'M PERIODICALLY AND IT DID
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION THAT THE A
ARE BE --
ENGAGE IN CREATING BOTH
PROCUREMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS TO INCENTIVIZE
ADDITIONAL USE OF RENEWABLE GAS
IN THE STATE AND SO CONSISTENT
WITH THAT RECOMMENDATION THE
CHANGE WAS MADE --
ALTHOUGH THAT THE BILL AND PRINT
DOES HAVE THE CPUC IMPLEMENTING
ALL RATE PAIR RELATED AND
UTILITY RELATED PIECES OF THE
BILL IT WOULD JUST BE AIR BE
SETTING THE TARGET [inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL.
DUMB SO I APPRECIATE THAT
EXPLANATION IN THE HISTORY ARM
ALL BE -- OF
FURTHER EXPLORING THAT ISSUE AS
A CONCERN NATURAL RESOURCES AYE
BY MAYBE OF STANDING ON THE THE
BILL TODAY --
BUT IF YOU NEED MY VOTE YOU HAVE
MY VOTE --
SO THERE'S PEOPLE WHO SAY THE
BIO DATA DAIRY INDUSTRY IS.
POLLUTING THEY DON'T SEEM TO
LIKE IT --
IN MY OPINION WHAT YOUR BILL
WILL DO WE JUST REDUCE POLLUTION
FROM THE DAIRY INDUSTRY.
AND ASIDE FROM --
YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT'S THE BEST THING THAT
CAN BE DONE UNLESS YOU JUST WANT
TO GET RID OF THE DAIRY INDUSTRY
PERHAPS YOU COULD AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH ME ON THAT.
WELL ABSOLUTELY I MEAN OF I
THINK GENERALLY PEOPLE.
THAT -- ARE
CRITICAL OF OF THIS BILL DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND KIND OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND BY OF
METHANE AND HOW.
IT ACTUALLY HAS A NAY IT OUT BY
USING GOING TO BUY A MATH THING
YOU ACTUALLY GO INTO.
A IN TERMS OF MEASURING THE
IMPACTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT YOU
COULD INTO NEGATIVE IMPACTS
WHERE.
IT'S ACTUALLY HELPING TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY IF THE MORE BY A MY
THING YOU YOU USE YOUR ACTUALLY
PROVING OR QUALITY SO YOU READ.
WHAT OTHERWISE WOULD BE --
METHANE GOING INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT NATURALLY YOU'RE
CAPTURING ALL EUROPE PREVENTING
THAT FROM GOING INTO SO IF YOU
LIVE IN AN AREA THAT'S IMPACTED
BY.
BY DAIRY INDUSTRY YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE.
THOSE AREAS CLEANER RANK AT AND
I I MEAN.
THAT'S NOT JUST GONNA HAPPEN ON
ITS OWN YOU ACTUALLY NEED A
PROGRAM TO DO THAT PROGRAMS COST
MONEY.
AND YOU GOTTA FIND A WAY TO
COMFORT THAT ENERGY INTO A
USABLE FORM.
BUT YOU KNOW FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
SAY THAT THEIR RATE PAYERS ARE
GOING TO BE FUNDING THIS.
THEY'RE REPAIRS ARE GOING TO BE
ALSO EMPLOYED BY THIS.
SO IT'S KIND OF A A CIRCLE IN
THAT YOU'RE RECYCLING.
A DOLLARS INSIDER STATE INSTEAD
OF STANDING EVERY TIME.
I USE NATURAL GAS ON MY STOVE
I'M ACTUALLY SENDING MY MONEY.
TO EITHER AUSTRALIA OR CANADA OR
SOME OTHER PART OF THE WORLD BUT
NOT CALIFORNIA WE'RE CREATING
JOBS THERE.
BUT WE'RE NOT CREATING JOBS HERE.
AND AND THERE IS A FINANCIAL
BENEFIT TO THAT THERE'S SUCH A
MEASURABLE.
BENEFIT TO OUR ECONOMY THAT WHEN
YOU LOOKED SIMPLY LOOK AT IT
SAID THIS IS GOING INCREASED
COSTS YOU BUT THIS IS ALSO THE
INCREASE JOBS.
AND IF YOU JUST TOOK THE COST
PART OF IT OUT.
I BET WE TOOK IT OUT WHAT THE
WHAT THE WHAT THE INTENT OF OF
FURTHER WORKING ON IT TO ENSURE
A WE WE WE WANNA.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN AND I COULD
AGREE THAT WE WANT.
BUT THERE IS NO WAY FORWARD ON
THIS BILL WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
OF WAY TO A INCENTIVIZE.
THE CREATION OF THESE JOBS THE
INCENTIVIZE IT AND IT'S JUST NOT
GONNA HAPPEN ON ITS OWN IF IT
DID WE WOULDN'T NEED THIS BUT WE
WANT TO BE TALK NEAR.
YEAH WHAT IN OUR STARTED SOLAR
WE WANNA START IT NGUYEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT WITHOUT COMING UP WITH
MANDATES LIKE THIS ONE WITHOUT
COMING UP WITH WAYS. TO FUND
THESE PROJECTS BUT NOW.
IT'S BECOME THE MOST COMPETITIVE
ENERGY SOURCE I THINK WE'RE
HEADED IN THAT DIRECTION BUT WE
GOT TO GIVE IT A LITTLE NUDGE.
AND THEN AND WE ARE ON OUR WAY
TO NOT ONLY CREATE A VERY
COMPETITIVE.
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
HELPING TO ADDRESS OUR
ENVIRONMENT PROBLEMS THERE'S
ANOTHER PART OF THIS THAT SAYS.
WE HAVE A PILOT PROGRAM.
WHY DO YOU FEEL THIS IS AND DID
NEEDED IN ADDITION TO THE PILOT
PROGRAM?
YOU WANNA CHECK INTO CHAIR
PLEASE SOFAS.
THERE IS AN ON GOING PILOT --
AT THIS TPC AT THAT DEAL
SPECIFICALLY WITH DAIRY PROJECTS
NOW IS DONE UP PURSUANT TO S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHERE
THERE WAS SOME QUESTION THERE
HADN'T BEEN ANY DAIRY PROJECTS
AS OF YET.
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
INTERCONNECTED AND THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY WAS ABLE --
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH SENATOR
LARA -- TO
CREATE A PILOT MECHANISM WHERE
1100% OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S NOT WHAT SENATOR HUESO IS
IS --
PROPOSING FOR THIS BILL IT
SOUNDS SOMETHING MORE CONSISTENT
WITH 50% WHICH IS AVAILABLE TO
OTHER INDUSTRIES BUT IT WAS IT
WAS A DAIRY SPECIFIC PILOT ON
THAT BEING SAID SO THERE ARE
OTHER SECTORS HERE WASTE WATER
LANDFILL ENDEAVORED ORGANIC
WASTE THAT ARE ENVISIONED NONE
OF THOSE ARE SUBJECT TO THE
PILOT.
THEY HAD BEEN WELL DEMONSTRATED
THE COSTS ARE WELL UNDERSTOOD IN
CALIFORNIA OF THOSE SECTORS --
AND SO GOES BEYOND DARIAN ALSO
IN THAT SAME THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE REPORT THAT WAS DONE BY
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
IT ACTUALLY SAYS --
YES EPC SHOULD CONTINUE WITH
THEIR PILOTS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME AIR BE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
ON PROCUREMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND WE
DID A CLARIFY THAT WITH THE CDC
TO MAKE SURE.
THEY DIDN'T MEAN THAT IT WOULD
BE PREMATURE AND AND THEY DID
CONFIRM THAT FOR US.
THAT'S WHY GOING.
I WASN'T CHAIRMAN A TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION SPECIFICALLY TO
ONE INDUSTRY.
THE SOLID WASTE RECYCLING
INDUSTRY AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
WE HAVE TWENTY MILLION TONS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO COME OUT OF THE
LANDFILL BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND GROWING.
SO THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AVENUES
THAT'S NOT A PILOT PROGRAM AYE
IN THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BUT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE REQUIRED.
US ALL THE MUNICIPALITIES ALL
THE COUNTIES AND ALL OF THEIR
PROVIDERS I TO TAKE THIS OUT OF
THE LANDFILL SO THIS IS A VERY
CRITICAL PIECE THAT WILL MOVE
THAT FORWARD.
WE THINK COST CONTAINMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY BUT AS THE
SENATOR SAID THERE HAS TO BE AN
INCENTIVE AND THIS IS THAT
INCENTIVE SO RELEASE HELP US DO
WHAT THE LAW THAT YOU ALL PASSED --
WITH SENATOR LARA DID YOU AND TO
ME IT ACTUALLY IS THE LANDFILL
PART.
BECAUSE IT IS UTTERLY
UNCONTROLLED AND UNCONTROLLABLE
UNLESS WE DO SOMETHING.
AND RIGHT NOW THE METHANE WE
HAVE.
OVER THE NEXT HUNDRED YEARS
COMING OUT.
IS GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE.
AND AGAIN IT'S A MATTER OF
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY
SHOWING THAT THIS CAN BE DONE.
I YOU HAVE TO PUT SOME MONEY IN
THE BEGINNING WITH I AM
CONCERNED THAT THE MONEY WAS NOW
TAKEN OUT BUT WELL WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT PROCESS
GOES ALONG --
ANYWAY I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
IS THERE A MOTION TO TO MOVE THE
BILL.
ITSELF.
OKAY NOW IT'S MOVED OUT.
I WAS [inaudible]
THE ISSUE AND I HAD TO WHICH IS
SIR.
A SENATOR --
COULD YOU ADDRESS THE CONCERNED
THAT THAT THIS PROCUREMENT
MANDATE WOULD --
INCENTIVIZE --
METHANE GENERATION RATHER THAN
MET METHANE AVOIDANCE
[inaudible]
WELL.
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE.
DOES THAT MEAN THE MOST MORE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA WANNA.
THROW OUR TRASH IN THE I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO ANSWER THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE SAYING THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA INCENTIVE WE'RE GONNA
MONETIZE --
RENEWABLE MATCH GETS MORE PEOPLE
ARE GONNA WANNA THROW TRASH IN
LANDFILLS NO WELL A FOR EXAMPLE
I'M LOOKING AT A A NASCAR LETTER
HERE FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE --
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT I I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
LIKE I SAID.
THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT WHEN YOU
CREATE A LAW SAYING THAT --
YOU KNOW WORK ON BIG THE
ENCOURAGE --
A A SPECIFIC INDUSTRY WILL NET
NATURAL GAS TO DEVELOP.
THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE GONNA WANT
ONE TO THROW TRASH.
WELL THERE ARE CONCERNED THAT
LOOK YOU PUT A FIGURE ON IT AND
MORE PEOPLE ARE GONNA WANNA.
ENGAGE IN THAT ACTIVITY THAT'S
WHY.
INITIALLY --
THERE'S A CAP ON ON THE PART.
TRYING TO GET AT THE THE AMOUNT
OF GAS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE OUT
THERE AND IT'S NOT.
I I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD ARGUMENT BECAUSE OF
I MEAN WHAT'S THE PRACTICAL
APPLICATION OF THAT ARGUMENT
MORE PEOPLE GOING TO WANT TO
KNOW HAS EVER TALK ABOUT DAIRIES
AND INCENTIVIZING LARGER HERD
SIZES.
AND AND THAT'S THE THING YOU
THINK PEOPLE WILL DO THAT AB OUT
OF THE CAR HAS ASKING A
PRODUCING MILK.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SELL MORE
GAS I I I DON'T KNOW MAY BE
MICHAEL YOU WANT A TICKET.
I JUST DON'T MICHAEL VOCAL OR ON
THEY HAVE TO THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS I WORK CLOSELY WITH
BOTH THE DAIRY INDUSTRIES IN THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY DEVELOPERS AND
THERE'S NO --
REALISM TO THE CONCERN THAT THIS
IS GOING TO INCENTIVIZE LARGER
DAIRIES.
THEORIES HAVE BEEN CONSOLIDATING
CALIFORNIA FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
WE HAVE FEWER DAIRIES --
AND THAT'S A TRULY UNFORTUNATE
THING IT'S A COMBINATION OF OF
YOU KNOW HOME REQUIREMENTS IN
LABOR COSTS AND OTHERS THAT ARE
CONSOLIDATING THE INDUSTRY.
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE WHATSOEVER
TO ADD COWS TO YOUR DAIRY TO
PRODUCE MORE METHANE SO YOU CAN
SELL IT UNDER THIS BILL RIGHT
THAT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY CRAZY
TALK.
THANK.
ON THAT NOTE --
SENATOR WE WE TURN TO YOU TO SEE
IF YOU HAVE MONEY.
ARE CLOSING THOUGHTS I JUST
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL TO A
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FRAWLEY WORK IN YOUR SUPPORT AND
HELPING US THROUGH THIS.
VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS WANT TO
KEEP IT MOVING FOR F. THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS NATURAL
RESOURCES WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE READ OUT INTO THE
RECORD [inaudible]
CALDERON.
I'M SORRY YET THE THE AMENDMENTS
WILL HAVE TO BE TAKEN IN
NATURISTS YES BECAUSE OF THE
BILL BE IN A PRESS THANK.
SO THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN TO NATURAL [inaudible]
LOCAL HOLDEN AYE AYE HOLDEN AYE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
OF BILLS ON CALL AND WILL KEEP
THE RULING OVER MUCH.
RULE [inaudible]
RESEARCH PER.
SO THAT WRAPS UP OUR AGENDA WE
WILL GO THROUGH FOR MEMBERS HAVE
TO ADD ON YEAH [inaudible]
I DID.
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH THE THE
BILLS FOR A ABSENT MEMBERS TO
ADD ON CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR SB SEVEN HUNDRED
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
S. B. SEVEN HUNDRED CALLING ADD
ONS.
CALLING OUT ON TO SB.
EIGHT NINETEEN EDUARDO GARCIA
SANTIAGO.
CALLING OUT ONTO TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
CALLING OUT ONTO [inaudible]
ELEVEN TEN FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I AND WATER GARCIA
[inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING
CALLING ADD ONS TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR EDUARDO GARCIA.
SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
FALL ON FOR THAT THE CALL ON S.
P. THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE SKINNER
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM NO [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
ADDING ON TO SB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE FRIEDMAN
.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE THAT THE ON
CALL [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
IT'S ON CALL [inaudible]
BURKE.
YOUR IT MUST YOU HAD ARE YOU
VOTED.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM. FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
CUNNINGHAM NO [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
REYES SANTIAGO.
ADDING ON TO FOURTEEN FORTY IT'S
ON CALL FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I CHEN [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible] FOURTEEN FORTY
PUT THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ON FOURTEEN FORTY HUESO
[inaudible]
RAZ.
REYES NOT VOTING [inaudible]
SANTIAGO
.
ADDING ON TO SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING.
EDUARDO GARCIA SANTIAGO.
CALLING OUT ONTO ELEVEN TEN
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I EDUARDO GARCIA.
REYES. ELEVEN TEN BUT THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
REYES AYE.
SANTIAGO TING
[inaudible]
RIGHT BACK [inaudible]
RIGHT YEAH [inaudible]
MARK
.
WITH YOUR VOTING AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE.
SANTIAGO.
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS FOR SP
EIGHT NINETEEN EDUARDO GARCIA.
I ATWATER SEE I SANTIAGO.
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS FOR S. B.
[inaudible]
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible] TEN EIGHTY NOT
VOTING EDUARDO GARCIA NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR ELEVEN TEN EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE SANTIAGO TING.
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS WAS BUILT
ON CALL [inaudible]
413-69 EDUARDO GARCIA.
I EDUARDO GARCIA AYE.
REYES. THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE REYES
I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
A THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE SCANNERS
OUT [inaudible]
CALLING. NINE FOR THE BILL IS
OUT ON SKINNER.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE LIFTING THE
CAR [inaudible]
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR CHEN
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA ARE EDUARDO
GARCIA I MAYES [inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE SANTIAGO.
US SP FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR LEYVA
IS OUT AND HAS EIGHT VOTES IN
FAVOR.
LIFTING THE CALL ON FOURTEEN
FORTY CHEN.
EGGMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I SANTIAGO TING.
TING NOT VOTING.
GALLAGHER CHANGING HIS VOTE FROM
NOT VOTING TO AYE.
REYES CHANGING HIS VOTE FROM.
I'M SORRY RED SHADING HER VOTE
FROM NOT VOTING TO AYE --
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY HUESO --
HAS EIGHT VOTES THAT GOES OUT.
ADDING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WHERE'S THE AYE SANTIAGO
.
ADD ONS TO ELEVEN TEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
KLEIN ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO
TING.
TING NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
FROM [inaudible]
OKAY.
SORT SOME GOOD THANK YOU.
I CAN THINK THANK THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING UP.
BOB A LOT.
NEVER NEVER TRY TO BE THE MOST
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
BUT SANTIAGO [inaudible]
NEXT [inaudible]
I'M.
THINGS YOU KNOW.
RIGHT.
HAVE A GOOD [inaudible]
PRESENT.
COULD THE DIFFICULT.
I THINK THAT [inaudible]
RICHARD.
OKAY CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FOR SB SEVEN HUNDRED WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
S. B. EIGHT NINETEEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE
.
KIND ABSENT MEMBERS FOR S. B.
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO NO.
MAKE CHANGE IN ABOUT NINETEEN MY
VOTE OF SENTIENT.
YEAH SANTIAGO CHANGING HIS VOTE
ON S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT FROM
NOTE TO NOT VOTING.
S. B. ELEVEN TEN CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
KLEIN ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CHEN I EGGMAN [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
PINE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR FOURTEEN FORTY THE CHAIR
MONNING AYE CHEN.
CHEN NO.
EGGMAN.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
KLEIN ABSENT MEMBERS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR MEETING FOR
TODAY THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED